ROUTE RESOURCES INCLUDING THE
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS A SEAT ON THE
SMARTER BALANCED EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE I JUST TOOK THAT
ROLE. AS OF JANUARY. OF TWENTY
TWENTY. AND WE OVERSEE THE
BALLOT BUDGET SOME POLICIES OF
THE CONSORTIUM THE CONSORTIUM
IN CONSULTATION WITH OTHER
STATE MEMBERS. SOME HAND THIS
OVER TO OUR BANK IS GOING TO
GET INTO A LITTLE BIT DEEPER.
THANKS TOTALLY YEAH. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHIU AND MEMBERS THE
SOME AT COMMITTEE MY NAME TONY
I'LL AND EGGS TO OF THIS ABOUT
ASSESSMENT CAN. CORNERSTONE OF
THE SMARTER BALANCED MISSION IS
TO PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
TEACHERS THAT HELP TEACHERS
HELP THEIR STUDENTS LEARN MORE
AS IT IS EDUCATORS WHO KNOW
THEIR NEEDS BEST SMART ABOUT
SAYS BROUGHT TOGETHER HUNDREDS
OF EDUCATORS TO DESIGN AND
BUILD AN ARRAY OF RESOURCES
INCLUDING SOMEBODY OF INTERIM
TESTING RESOURCES THAT SUPPORT
THE FORMATIVE PROCESS FROM THE
BEGINNING CALIFORNIA EDUCATE
EDUCATORS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
IMMENSELY TO BUILDING THIS
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM THE
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES
PROVIDED BY SPIDER BOUNCE AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ARE FREE TO TEACHERS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND OUR LINE TO
THE ACADEMIC STANDARDS I WILL
HIGHLIGHT A FEW OF THOSE
RESOURCES NOW TOOLS FOR
TEACHERS IS A NEW WEBSITE
COMING IN JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
DESIGNED WITH SIGNIFICANT INPUT
BY EDUCATORS. BASED ON FEEDBACK
REGARDING THE DIGITAL LIBRARY
AND THROUGH WORKSHOPS AND FOCUS%
GROUPS ABOUT TOOLS FOR
TEACHERS. TOOLS FOR TEACHERS IS
DESIGNED TO HELP SAVE TEACHERS
TIME BY PROVIDING HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES AND
ACTIVITIES TO HELP THEM IMPROVE
STUDENT LEARNING LEARNING ALL
THE RESOURCES AND TOOLS FOR
TEACHERS ARE CREATED AND
APPROVED BY EDUCATORS. AND
TOOLS FOR TEACHERS WILL REPLACE
THE CURRENT DIGITAL LIBRARY. A
FEW OF THE KEY FEATURES FOR
TOOL FOR TEACHERS INCLUDE
IMPROVED CONNECTIONS PLAYLIST
THAT GUY TEACHERS REGARDING THE
NEXT STEPS THEY MAY CONSIDER
BASED ON THE RESULTS OF THE
INTERIM. AND FOCUSED INTERIM
ASSESSMENTS IMPROVED FORMATIVE
RESOURCES THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE
DYNAMIC IN EASY TO READ AND A
SEARCH FEATURE THAT IS DESIGNED
TO HELP TEACHERS QUICKLY FIND
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED. IN
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY EDUCATORS
WILL HAVE EARLY ACCESS TO THE
SITE IN TIME FOR SUMMER
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AND THE
GRAND OPENING WILL BE IN
SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY.
SMART AMOUNTS INTERIM SEVEN
IT'S IN OUR SUSSMAN. TEACHERS
BY THEM PERIODICALLY CHECK WITH
STUDENTS KNOW WE CAN DO. EARLY
FEEDBACK FROM T. WAS A OUR OLD
ENORMOUS EXPENSE YOU CHEN. AND
THEN FOLLOW TWO THOUSAND. WERE
RELEASED THE FIRST WAVE OF
FOCUS ENORMOUS ASMAN BLOCKS
WHICH PROVIDE EDUCATORS WITH
MORE FIND GREAT INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR STUDENTS. EACH YEAR
MORE TEACHERS IN CALIFORNIA USE
THE INNERMOST ASPIN'S LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA ADMINISTERED MORE
THAN ELEVEN MILLION ENORMOUS
ASPENS AND THAT NUMBER IS ON
TRACK TO INCREASE THIS YEAR.
EACH ENORMOUS SUSSMAN BLOCK HAS
A CONNECTIONS PLAY LESS THAT
PROVIDES EDUCATORS WITH
SUGGESTIONS REGARDING NEXT
STEPS THAT THEY MAY WANT TO
TAKE. BASED ON THEIR STRANGE
PERFORMANCE AND AS I DESCRIBED
PREVIOUSLY THOSE CONNECTIONS
ARE CREATED BY THEIR PEERS. BY
LATE SPRING WE PLAN TO RELEASE
THE ENHANCEMENT FOR TEACHERS TO
PRINT ENORMOUS SAUCEPAN ITEMS
AND THAT'S IN LARGE PART- PER
THE REQUESTED SUGGESTION. OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE OVER A
HUNDRED INTERNET SUSSMAN'S
AVAILABLE WITH ALMOST FIFTY
MORE ON THE WAY. OVER THE NEXT
TWO YEARS. WE ALSO ARE- HAVE
RECENTLY RELEASED THE SMARTER
CONTENT EXPLORE- THAT WILL- WAS
RELEASED IN FALL OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- WHICH HELPS
TEACHERS LEARN HOW TEST
QUESTIONS ARE DESIGNED AND
SCORE TO PROVIDE EVIDENCE OF
WHAT STUDENTS KNOW WE CAN DO.
TEACHERS CAN USE THE WEBSITE TO
SUPPORT THEIR INSTRUCTION PLAN
ACTIVITIES AND UNDERSTAND HOW
SMART ABOUNDS CLAIMS AND
TARGETS A LINE TO THEIR CONTENT
STANDARDS WITH THE SMARTER
BOUNCE COTTON EXPLORED TEACHERS
CAN LEARN ABOUT TEST
DEVELOPMENT WITH RESOURCES LIKE
CONSTRUCT RELEVENT VOCABULARY
BLUEPRINTS AND SCORING RUBRICS.
THE CONTENT EXPLORE WILL BE
ENHANCED IN MARCH- TO INCLUDE A
DECRIPTION OF THE PROGRESSION
OF KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS FOR
EACH AND EVERY TARGET. THAT
HELPS. EDUCATORS BETTER
SCAFFOLD RESOURCES FOR STUDENTS
TO HELP THEM REACH PROFICIENCY.
WHAT ONE OF THE CORE MISS OF
SPY BOUNCE TO MAKE THE ASSESSED
ACCESSIBLE FOR ALL STUDENTS IN
SPARTA BOUNCE IS AN INDUSTRY
LEADER AND ACCESSIBILITY
RESOURCES. SMARTER BALANCED
PROVIDES UNMATCHED
ACCESSIBILITY FEATURES SUCH AS
BRAILLE SPANISH TRANSLATIONS
AND GLOSSARIES IN MORE THAN TEN
LANGUAGES AS WELL AS TRANSLATED
TEST CORRECTIONS IN NINETEEN
LANGUAGE LET NINETEEN
LANGUAGES. THIS YEAR WE ADDED
PERMISO SMALLEY TOWARD LANGUAGE
CLASS RACE. THIS YEAR WE ALSO
ADDED AN ILLUSTRATION GLOSSARY
IN MATHEMATICS WHICH HELP
STUDENTS UNDERSTAND WORDS OR
PHRASES IN TEST QUESTIONS WHEN
THEY MAY NOT OTHERWISE BENEFIT
FROM TAX PLATE BASE GLOSSARIES
OR AMERICAN SIGN LANGUAGE
VIDEOS. BY USING PICTURES WHICH
IS- NO ONE ELSE IS DOING THIS
WORK- AND WE'RE GETTING REALLY
POSITIVE FEEDBACK ABOUT THAT.
SMART BOUNCE WORK WITH ANY.
STUDENTS AND EXPERTS IN THE
FIELD DESIGN AND TEST THE
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM WE WORK WITH
ADVISORY PANELS ON ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES TO ENSURE
THAT ASSESSMENTS ARE DEVELOPED
WITH- PRINCIPLES OF UNIVERSES.
UNIVERSALISM AND RESEARCH BASED
BEST PRACTICES WE'VE
COLLABORATED WITH EDUCATORS TO
DEVELOP INSTRUCTIONAL
ACCESSIBILITY STRATEGIES THAT
HELP EDUCATORS CONNECT
CLASSROOM USE OF ACCESSIBILITY
PRACTICES TO ACCESSIBILITY
RESOURCES OFFERED ON THE AN ARM
AND SOMEBODY'S ASSESSMENTS. AND
THEN I WILL ASK MOUTH SAYING-
TO CONTINUE. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND MEMBERS
OF THIS AND THE EDUCATION. MY
NAME MELVIN AS MEN I AM THE
DOOR FOR THE DEVELOP AND
MYSTERY TO AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. AND I
WILL PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THE
NEWLY RELEASED SAMPLE ITEMS. SO
BY WORKING WITH EDUCATORS FOR
THE LAST MONTH- MULTIPLE YEARS
THE CONSORTIUM HAS CREATED-
QUESTION BANK THAT IS LARGE
ENOUGH AT THIS TIME THEY WERE
ABLE TO RELEASE- TEST MORE TEST
QUESTIONS. AND WE JUST RELEASED
A HUNDRED FOR SAMPLE TEST
QUESTIONS FROM THE SUMMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS- IN MATH AND THE LA
AND ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS IN
THE LAST OF. IT EARLIER THIS
MONTH ACTUALLY. AN ENGINE TO
USE THESE NEW SAMPLE ITEM OR
CLICK TEST CA. PRETTY MUCH
TO UNDERSTAND HOW SMARTER
BALANCED MEASURES COLLEGE AND
CAREER READY CONTENT. IT ALSO
TO LEARN HOW ITEMS AND TASKS
ARE SCORED. AND THEN TO
INTERACT WITH THE FULL RANGE OF
QUESTION TYPES AND
ACCESSIBILITY RESOURCES THAT
TONY MENTIONED KINDA LIKE SEE
WHAT ALL THOSE ACCESSIBILITY
RESOURCES LOOK LIKE IN THE
SYSTEM. AND THEN ANOTHER
ADDITION TO THE SAMPLE ITEMS-
WEBSITE IS STUDENT WRITING
SAMPLES FOR PERFORMANCE TASKS
AND THOSE ARE- REALLY SAMPLES
THAT INCLUDE EXPLANATIONS TO
HELP. TEACHERS BETTER
UNDERSTAND HOW THE PAPERS WERE
SCORED SO IT'S REALLY LIKE A
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
OPPORTUNITY AS WELL. THE BASE
IMPART AGAIN ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL'S TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN LEGISLATION WE BEGAN A
SERIES OF ENHANCEMENTS TO THE
SAMPLE ITEMS WEBSITE- INCLUDING
THE ABILITY TO PRINT THE
QUESTIONS SO THAT A TEACHERS
MAY USE THE SAMPLE ITEMS AS
PART OF THEIR FORMATIVE
PROCESS- AND THIS YEAR OR IF
THEY LATE MAY EDUCATE. WILL BE
ABLETO FIND ITEMS BY CONTENT
STANDARDS ON THE SAMPLE- ITEMS
WEBSITE. SO TO SHARE ANOTHER
SYSTEM THAT WE ARE A BILL IN
AND IT'S BECAUSE FOR U IT'S
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATOR
REPORTING SYSTEM THIS IS AN
INTER ACTIVE ON MY REPORTING
WEBSITE. THAT ALLOWS TEACHERS
AND ADMINISTRATORS TO- ACT
ACCESS DETAILS STUDENT
PERFORMANCE INFORMATION. AND
THAT MEANS THAT THE USERS OF
THE SYSTEMS CAN VIEW THE-STUDENT DATA BY DISTRICT BY
SCHOOL AND BY- GRADE LEVEL AND
THEY MAY ALSO VIEW DOWNLOAD THE
RESULTS AND- INDIVIDUAL STUDENT
REPORTS FOR THE STUDENTS. THE
SYSTEM WAS OVER HALL BASED ON
ADVICE FROM THAT CALIFORNIA'S
EDUCATORS- MAINLY AND THAT
INCLUDES THAT THEY WANTED TO
HAVE A SUMMARY OF PERFORMANCE
FOR TESTS OF A TEACHER'S CLASS
SO TEACHER GIVES A NUMBER OF
TESTS AND- TO BE ABLE TO GET A
SUMMARY OF HOW THE STUDENTS PUT.
QUICKLY IT DRAWS TO SCORE
REPORTS AS I'M IT LINKS TO IN.
RESOURCES AFTER THE STUDENTS
GET A CERTAIN. LEVEL WHAT DO
YOU DO WITH THEM WHAT KIND OF
RESOURCES CAN YOU DO HOW CAN
YOU LIKE CHALLENGE THEIR
LEARNING A LITTLE BIT MORE.
ALSO IN FOR UP THE- THAT THE
STUDENTS RESPONDING TO. SPOT
RESPONDED TO INCLUDING LIKE THE
CONTENTS DANDER IN MEASURES AND
ACCESS TO THE STUDENT RESPONSES
TO THE QUESTIONS AND THE
ABILITY TO LOOK AT THE
INCORRECT ANSWERS THAT ARE MOST
COMMONLY. OF THAT SELECTED BY
THE STUDENTS SO THAT YOU COULD
FOCUS ON TEACHING OR RE
TEACHING. IF I WOULD NUMBER
STUDENTS GOT IT WRONG BUT LONG
ANSWER ONE QUESTION WRONG YOU
SHOULD PROBABLY LOOK AT MAYBE
WE NEED TO REACH SOMETHING. SO
PRETTY MUCH O DURING THE NEXT
TWO YEARS STUDENT RESULTS FROM
ALL CAST. ASSESSMENTS WILL BE
ADDED TO THE CALIFORNIA
REPORTING SYSTEM. PROVIDING OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS A SINGLE
PLATFORM TO ASK ACCESS ALL OF
OUR CAST AND OTHER ASSESSMENTS
RESULTS IN ONE SINGLE PLACE.
THANK SO I'D LIKE TO CONCLUDE
WITH SHARING A LITTLE BIT OF A
AND TOTALSTORY THAT HAPPENED
ABOUT FOUR WEEKS AGO I WAS
ASKED TO COME IN SUPPORT OF
SCHOOL DISTRICT BECAUSE I WAS A
FORMER PRINCIPAL THERE AND THE
NEW MY ROLE IN NEW WITH ACCESS
I HAD TO. RESOURCES AND
SUPPORTS ANDTHEY WERE
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT HOW
THEY COULD TAKE THE REPORTS
COMING FROM THE EDUCATOR
PORTING SYSTEM AND REALLY
UTILIZING THEM AS THE
FOUNDATION FOR CONVERSATIONS
AROUND PLANNING THEIR
INSTRUCTION. AND PLANNING AND
REALLY HELPING THEM UNDERSTAND
WHAT PEDAGOGIES WOULD BE BEST
PRACTICE FOR THE STUDENTS THAT
THEY SERVED AND SO IT WAS A
WHOLE STAFF MEETING THEY HAD
PRINCIPLES FROM ALL THE OTHERS
SCHOOLS JOIN US AND WE DIVED
INTO HOW THEY COULD UTILIZE ALL
THESE RESOURCES BECAUSE THEY WE
UNDERSTAND THAT CURRICULUM
INSTRUCTION AND ASSESSMENT ARE
INTER DEPENDENT OF EACH OTHER.
THE ASSESSMENT ELEMENTS THAT WE
GET THE INFORMATION WE GET IS
JUST ONE PIECE OF THE PUZZLE
ABOUT HOW OUR STUDENTS ARE
DOING. LOOKING AT STUDENT WORK.
LOOKING AT THE FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS LOOKING AT THE
OTHER INFORMAL FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE. TEACHERS
CONDUCT ON A DAILY BASIS
SOMETIMES. EVERY TEN MINUTES IN
THE CLASSROOM HOPES THEM
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS. AND SO FROM THAT THEY
FELT THAT THIS WAS EXTREMELY
VALUABLE TO THEM AND FURTHER
GUIDING THEIR INSTRUCTIONAL
PRACTICES. AND BEING PRO ACTIVE
TO MEETING THE NEEDS OF THEIR
STUDENTS VERSUS BEING REACTIVE.
AND SO THAT WAS VERY EXCITING
TO BE A PART OF AND TO WATCH
THOSE LIGHT BULBS GO OFF. WITH
ALL OF THE TEACHERS AND
PRINCIPALS THAT ARE SERVING OUR
THE STUDENTS. SO OVERALL WE
BELIEVE THAT A HIGH QUALITY
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM SUCH A
SMARTER BALANCED CAN PROVIDE
INFORMATION AND TOOLS FOR
TEACHERS TO IMPROVE
INSTRUCTION. AND HELP STUDENTS
SUCCEED REGARDLESS OF
DISABILITY OR LANGUAGE NEEDS
THE SMARTER BALANCED ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM HAS BEEN BUILT WITH
TEACHER INPUT FOR TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS TO USE. TEACHERS CAN
ACCESS RESOURCES INCLUDING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AS AN
INSTRUCTIONAL RESOURCES TO
SUPPORT THAT STUDENT LEARNING
AS I'VE TALKED ABOUT. AND THEY
CAN ALSO USE OPTIONAL FLEXIBLE
INTERIM ASSESSMENTS AND SUCH AS
THE INTERIM ASSESSMENT BLOCKS
THAT ARE FOCUSED IN ON A
DISCREET SKILL THAT THEY MADE
ME MORE INFORMATION ABOUT FOR
THEIR STUDENTS. AND THE
STUDENTS CAN PARTICIPATE IN THE
SUMMIT AT THE END OF THE YEAR
TASK THE ONES THAT YOU WERE
SPEAKING TO. AND IN ORDER TO
MEASURE THAT ACHIEVEMENT GROW.
AND IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE ARTS
AND MATH AND NOW WE HAVE OUR
SCIENCE ASSESSMENT THE ONLINE
FORMAT IS WHAT OUR STUDENTS
KNOW IT'S WHAT THEY WERE BORN
INTO RIGHT THEY ARE. ARE
DIGITAL NATIVES WE ARE MORE OF
THE DIGITAL IMMIGRANTS AND SO
BECAUSE OF THAT IT HELPS THEM
UNDERSTAND HOW TO UTILIZE
TECHNOLOGY AND THEIR PROBLEM
SOLVING AND CRITICAL THINKING
SKILLS. AND THAT THEY WILL NEED
TO. NOW AND BEYOND. THE THANK
YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS ARE JUST A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AND I'LL SEE IF ANY
OF THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY THOUGHTS OR OR
QUESTIONS- AND THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOU'RE REFERENCING
MY EFFORTS TO KINDA. YOU KNOW
MOVE US ON. YOU KNOW CAN REBOOT
THE TAP ALL WRITTEN SOME WAY
AND BILL I PAY SUCCESS. BUT
I'LL BE HONEST YOU YOU
SHOULDN'T BE RESPONDING TO ME
SHOULD REALLY BE SPOT RESPOND
TO THE CLASSROOM. THE NEED TO
THE TEACHERS AND ULTIMATELY
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA SO. HOW
DOES THE CONSORTIUM HOW DO THEY
CONNECT THE CLASSROOM HOW DO
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON. IN
THE CLASSROOM IS THERE TO HAVE
A FORMAL PROCESS FOR THAT. I
MEAN IT'S GREAT THAT YOU KNOW
THIS TEST WAS PUT TOGETHER THE
TEACHER STARTED GIVING IN IN
THE PLATFORMS ARE RATHER
CONFUSING I TOOK THE FOURTH
RADIO A TEST. THE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS PORTION WASN'T
DIFFICULT BUT QUITE FRANKLY
MATCH NAME THROUGH THE PROGRAM
WAS A LITTLE DIFFICULT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT BUT I HAD A
CENTER. THEN THAT'S JUST MORE
OF A PROCESS ISSUE BUT HOW. YOU
HEARING FROM THE- ON AND WHAT
NEEDS TO BE WOULD DONE WHAT
TOOLS. NEED NEW TEACHERS NEED
TO BE MORE SUCCESSFUL.
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL BUT
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION SO- THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF VENUES FOR THAT- WITH THE
FIRST AND MOST IMPORTANT IS
THAT- WE RECEIVE THE FEEDBACK
FROM THE MEMBER STATE THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION SO- THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAS. MULTIPLE
MEETINGS THROUGHOUT THE YEAR
WHERE THEY RECEIVE FEEDBACK
DIRECTLY FROM THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RECEIVE IT FROM THE
TEACHER'S SO THERE'S-
INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR IN WHICH THAT. FEEDBACK IS
BEING PROVIDED UP FROM THE FROM
THE TEACHERS THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
THEN- THOSE- DEPARTMENTS OF
EDUCATION BRING THOSE
ENHANCEMENTS ENHANCEMENT
REQUESTS- IN THE FORM OF
PROPOSALS- AND- PROGRAM CHANGES
AND- AND BUDGET SUGGESTIONS TO
THE CONSORTIUM- AND THAT ALL
GETS WRAPPED UP IN THE ANNUAL
BUDGET PROCESS THAT WE ENGAGE
AND DISCUSSIONS THAT WE HAVE AS
AT OUR MADE COLLABORATION
CONFERENCE. WE ALSO HAVE-
SOMETHING THAT'S THE
PERFORMANCE AND PRACTICES
COMMITTEE OF WHICH THERE ARE-
SEVERAL CALIFORNIANS ON OF FOUR
OF WHICH WE- IN DEEP LEARNING-
WITH WITH THOSE FOLKS. IN WHICH
THEY LEARN ABOUT THE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF THE ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM- WE PARTICIPATE IN
DESIGN AND DISCUSSIONS WITH A
MASK THEM UP THEIR ECONOMIC OF.
THIS APPROACH THIS APPROACH AND
GET THEIR IF YOU. AS WE THEN
PER. SOLUTIONS TO THE- THAT
WE'RE THAT HEARING ABOUT THE
WORK THAT WE'RE HERE ABOUT AND.
AND HE- NO I THAT HAVE OUR THIS
ADVOCATES GROUPS THAT ALSO TOOK
INFORMATION FROM EDGE SO THERE
THREE DIFFERENT THAN WHERE WE
CAN THAT IN. SO THAT'S A LOT
RIGHT THERE SO CAL A THAT THE
FROM WE HAVE THE FOR THE
LARGEST OF THE CONSOLE AT HOW
HOW DOES THE VOTING I MEAN MY
MIGHT WHAT I'M SEEING RIGHT ARE
YOU JUST DESCRIBED ME POLITBURO
IS JUST SOUNDS ME LIKE A GONNA
TAKE FOR TO GET ANYTHING DONE
INSIDE THE CONSORTIUM IN OF ALL
FOR CALIBER THE LAW MEMBER OF
THE CONSUMER WHO DO YOU GO
GRAYSON YOU THE PER THAT WROTE
COUNT. AND HOW THE SECOND
COMMITTEE THEN START I ONCE WE
SO HAVE TO VOTE SO OF ELEVEN.
NO THAT'S NOT HOW THIS IS SET.
FROM I AND I LEARNING ATHIS IS
THE- SO WE THE EXACT. COMMITTEE
THAT HAD. HOW MANY STATE TO
REPRESENT ON THE EXACT
COMMITTEE. ON THE- COMMITTEE
THERE ARE. THIRTY TWO K. ARE
THE EXACT COMMITTEE WE IS OUT
AT REP. HIGHER IN. HIGHER NAY.
DOES CSU AS A RED. OF OKAY SO
HI HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE THE
EXACT COMMITTEE. THERE ARE
CURRENTLY CSUS HEATS LOTS OF IS
ON FILLED WITH HAVE WE HAVE TO
OF A- SO WE A- OKAY WE DON'T
HAVE THEM REP GIVEN THE OF WE
HAVE ONE COULD ARE. SO YEAH
THAT IS ACCURATE OKAY THANK YOU
AND I LISTEN I WEREN'T COVERS
ALL. TO BE A STRONGER VOICE IN
THAT BECAUSE I THINK WE TO MAKE
CHANGE. OKAY CHANGES TO SERVE
NEEDS FOR. TO THE CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL THE CLASSROOM. YEAH
WE'RE HERE SOME. FROM THE
GROUND AND THE NEXT I DON'T
KNOW HERE TO BE AS MUCH AS I
READ THINK YOU NEED TO ENGAGED
AND I AND YOU DON'T TO WAIT FOR
A FROM MODOC. OKAY QUE HOLDEN
JUST OUT OF THE OTHER I DON'T I
TAKE ALL AFTERNOON HERE. OKAY
SO I HAVE YOU ADDRESSING THE
DIGITAL LIBRARY I MEAN I THINK
YOU KNOW. JUST TO HELP ME
DELIVER MY LESSONS SO I HOPE
YOU'RE THINKING IN THAT. MANNER
NOT JUST. RUNNING AND I AND WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE. YOU KNOW.
I'VE I'VE HAD A LOT OF FOLKS
FROM INDUSTRY SAY HEY LOOK AT
ALL THESE LESSONS BY THE READY
THE ITEM THE LESSON PLANS. WHAT
I YOU KNOW THAT'S THE ART OF
TEACHING I DEVELOP MY LESSON
PLANS TO MEET MY NEEDS TO THE
STATE HOW WE COMMUNICATE WITH
EACH OTHER. BUT I NEED
RESOURCES. AND THAT'S WHY I'M
GONNA JUMP TO THE FORMATIVE
QUESTION. YEAH I HEARD YOU TALK
ABOUT INTERIM BUT- IF WE LOOK
AT THE ORIGINAL CODE SECTION AS
ORIGINALLY CONTEMPLATED THE
ASPECTS SYSTEM. IN CALIFORNIA
STATE CODE SPEAKS TO FORMATIVE.
YEAH I DON'T SEE MUCH ON THE
FORMATIVE FRONT I SEE SOME
INTERIM THERE'S BEEN SOME
ALTERATIONS OF THAT TO MAKE IT.
SO THE CLASSROOM TEACHERS LOW
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER COULD
IDENTIFY. HOW OTHER STUDENTS
ARE DOING ON ON THOSE STANDARDS
WOULD. WHEN CAN WE GET MORE
FORMATIVE. ARE YOU GOING TO TRY
ARE YOU. SO AS AS THE
CONSORTIUM DEFINES THE
FORMATIVE- PROCESS THE TOOLS
FOR TEACHERS AYE- I AM
CONFIDENT WILL BETTER ADDRESS-
BOTH MY AND HOPEFULLY YOUR
DEFINITION OF FORMATIVE
PROCESS- I AGREE- WE DID NOT
HIT THE MARK ON THE DIGITAL
LIBRARY IT WAS THE RESOURCES
WERE NOT- WE'RE NOT ENGAGING-
THEY WERE NOT HELLO THEY WERE
NOT- CONSISTENTLY ORGANIZED-
THEY OVER HALF EMPHASIZE
PROCESS AND THEY DIDN'T-
SUFFICIENTLY ADDRESS RESOURCE-
AND I THINK THERE IS A
PARTICULAR. GROUP OF PEOPLE
THAT WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERY TIME YOU LOOKED AT A
RESOURCE YOU YOU SAW THE ENTIRE
FORMATIVE PROCESS LAID OUT- SO
WHAT WE REALLY FOCUSED ON WAS-
BEING AND ISN'T THAT- THERE ARE
GOING TO BE MASTER TEACHERS
THEY'RE GONNA BE USING THAT AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE OFFICE
TEACHERS. AND SO BEING ABLE TO
TURN THE DIAL OFF AND LETTING
PEOPLE SEE GO INTO THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED BEING
ABLE TO SEE MULTIPLE STEPS THEY
WANT SEE STEPS BEING. JUST THE
RESOURCES THEY AND WHY IF THEY
IF THEY KNOW THE MUSCLES I'M
KIND OF CONFUSED WITH THE WIND
I'M STARTING TO PAY OFF
MULTIPLES WHEN I'M TO SEE IS I
WANT. I WANT QUESTION I WANT TO
SEE I WANT TO SEE WHAT THE TEST
IS THE I DON'T TEACH THE- EVERY.
BUT I CERTAINLY WANT TO ACCESS
TO IT SO I CAN EVEN AT THE END
OF THE DAY I CAN PUT UP ONE
QUESTION. AND WE CAN VERBALLY
GOAL OR IT'LL TAKE THREE
MINUTES NO IT'S A IT'S A QUICK
THING. SO THAT'S SO SOME F THE
MEN ARE DOWN- THE OF THE FOR-
IS SO WE WILL BE MAKING
AVAILABLE FREE IN TERM
ASSESSMENT ITEMS IN A POOL-
WHICH WILL ALLOW- TEACHERS TO
SELECT A PARTICULAR ITEM AND
PRINT ABOUT AND PRESENT THEM IN
AS PART OF A FORMATIVE PROCESS
WHICH MAKES AN AVAILABLE- A
LITTLE BIT MORE EASIER AS PART
OF THE FORMATIVE- SO AS A SORT
pLIBRARY IS OF MORE ABOUT-
STRUCTURING AN ACTIVITY IN A
LISTENINGSPECIFIC INFORMATION
IN SUPPORT OF- ELICITING.
INFORMATION TO UNDERSTAND
MISCONCEPTIONS AND- AND TO
SOLIDIFY- DETERMINE
PROFICIENCY- AS PART OF A FOUR
MINUTE PROCESS WE'RE WE'RE
TRYING TO. BOTH OF THOSE TOOLS-
IN AS LARGE AS PART OF THE
LARGER FORMATIVE PROCESS OKAY
THANK YOU WANT ONE MAYBE THIS
IS JUST ON A LEAVE THIS
QUESTION ON THE TABLE. BUT
BEHIND ME BUT- REALLY I DON'T
SEE ENOUGH EMPHASIS ON THE
FORMATIVE SO I JUST WANT TO
TAKE HIS BACK TO THE CONSORTIUM
IF YOU COULD OKAY DESCRIPTION-
IT AND REALLY FOCUS ON THE
FORUM FORMATIVE ELEMENTS FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE THAT'S REALLY
NEEDS WHAT HAPPENS. WHAT NEEDS
TO HAPPEN BECAUSE AGAIN I. THE
SUMMATIVE IS PRETTY MUCH DONE
WE KNOW THAT IT'S BAKED QUE-
BUT I'M REALLY NOT SEEN A LOT
EMPHASIS EMPHASIS ON THE FORM
GIVEN THE AND WHAT HAPPENS IS.
AGAIN WHEN THE TEACHERS AT TEN.
ENGINE TO A THE EDGE WHEN THEY
GOT THE TEST. RIGHT AND AGAIN I
SAID I DON'T WANT THEM TESTING
ALL DAY BUT I WANT THEM TO HAVE
THE TOOLS NECESSARY. TO MATCH.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE TEST RECORD
EITHER WITH TEST REQUIRES OUR
STUDENTS SO JUST TAKE THAT
BACK. YOU HEARD ME SAY I DON'T
BELIEVE. YOU YOU- ARE REALLY
BEING VERY AGGRESSIVE ON THE
FORMATIVE FRONT. OKAY AND I
JUST CUT A COUPLE OTHER
QUESTIONS JUST QUIT CANCER THE
TEST LANCASTER ANYWAY ANYTHING
WE CAN DO TO SHORTEN THE
TESTING AT THE SAME DATA. OR OR
OR- SO WE HAVE BEEN DOING
STUDIES ON THE LENGTH OF THE
TESTING NO THAT WE STARTED
WITHOUT WITH SCIENCE I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK TO
THE LENGTH OF THE SCIENCE AND
FILAMENT MAYBE PERHAPS JUST THE
ENGLISH AND MATH AND SMARTER
SINCE WORK ON AYE AYE REFERRING
TO JUST THE- SMARTER BALANCED.
IT ENGLISH AND MATH. BECAUSE
THE SCIENCES- SEPARATE YES
SEPARATE. YEAH SO ENGLISH AND I
JUST THINK SO ARE IS THERE
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO SHORTEN
THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT TAKES A
TEST BECAUSE YOU KNOW SCHOOL
SET ASIDE TWO THREE WEEKS OF
THE YEAR OR EVERYTHING STERN
SIDE DOWN BECAUSE IT'S TESTING
TIME TESTING TIME. IS THERE
ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO ELIMINATE
THAT DINO SO SOMEONE OF A DIE
WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE CONSTANTLY
LOOKING AT THAT- WE'RE-
INVESTIGATING- AS A SLIMMER
DIRECTIONS SAT ON THE
PERFORMANCE TASK- FOR E. LA- TO
REDUCE THE VOLUME OF READING
THAT A STUDENT NEEDS TO DO TO
UNDERSTAND THE PERFORMANCE HAS
SO- WE PLAN TO FIELD TEST THAT.
THIS UPCOMING SPRING- TO REDUCE
THE COMPLEXITY REDUCE LIVE
READING ALOUD SO ARE WERE
OPTIMISTIC THAT THAT WILL
REDUCE THE- THE- READING TIME
FOR THE LA TEST- IT'S REALLY
THE NUMBER IT APPEARS THE
NUMBER OF STIMULI THAT A
STUDENT READ. OUT OF RIGHT THAT
IS DOES THIS IS REALLY A IN. IN
THE TOTAL TESTING SITE SO WILL
ABSOLUTELY CONTINUE TO LOOK AT
THAT- WILL BE HAPPY TO CONTINUE
TO TALK ABOUT THAT- AND IT'S-
ULTIMATELY A COMPROMISE
BETWEEN- THE AMOUNT OF A XIN
WANTS OUT OF IT AND KIND OF
TIME THAT IT TAKES ENTER SO.
WILL COTINUE TO WORK WITH PART
AND CAN TO TRY DRESS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU- IN JUST A COUPLE OF
JUST TESTING PLATFORM THERE'S
BEEN AN ANSWER THAT I
APPRECIATE THAT I HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO SLEEP. THAT TO
SAMPLE SHE WOULD REST SOME OF
THE HEY I THINK BLEEDS INTO MY
FORM COM. TO USERS THE TEACHERS
NEED. YEAH AND THAT I'M GONNA
BE QUITE IF THERE ARE OTHERS
WHO WISH TO SHARE ANY THOUGHTS
OR HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. NOPE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO ONE OF
OUR PANELISTS MAKE IT. THE
NUMBER. AND WE'RE NOW GOING TO
BRING UP- PANEL NUMBER TWO AND
THESE ARE THE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND THAT ADMINISTER THE TEST
AND- OUR INNER SCHOOLS JUST
ABOUT EVERY DAY IF NOT EVERY
DAY WILL. FIRST BRING UP-
MICHAEL FOR CHAT. IS THE MATH
INSTRUCTIONAL COACH FROM JULIE
AND LEAST TAG ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL. AND HE'S HERE OKAY.
HE'S HERE FROM THE SAME SCHOOL
AS MISS HOMES WHAT NOT
INTRODUCE WHO WAS FIRST ON THE
LISTER. SHE IS PRINCIPLE- JULIE
AND THE STAG ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
IN THERE IN THE SENATE FROM THE
SAN MARCOS. UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. AND THEN WILL ALSO
BRING UP- DAVID LAWLER USE THE
ENGLISH TEACHER FROM KERN HIGH
SCHOOL DAVID. AREAS AND
CHRISTOPHER MOORE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT FOR EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FROM THE ELDORADO.
UNION HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE THANK
YOU FOR GIVING US TIME OUT OF
YOUR DâN INTO SOME OF YOU.
TRAVEL FROM FAR FREE SHEET THAT
VERY MUCH WE'RE GONNA START
WITH OUR PRINCIPLE THIS ON
ANDREA HOMES. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND
MEMBERS OF THE EDUCATIONAL
COMMITTEE WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL
TO BE HERE. AND AGAIN I'M ENTRY
HOMES IN THE PRINCIPLE
CHILLINGLY SINUSES MIKE HE'S MY
MATH COACH- I WANTED TO TAKE A
MINUTE TO TELL YOU A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT MY SCHOOL GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT FROM THE LENS THAT WE
ARE SPEAKING TO TODAY- AND- WE
ARE. HEY WE ARE PART OF SAN
MARCOS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. OUR SCHOOL
HAS ROUGHLY SEVEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS 80% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE AT THE POVERTY LINE 78% ARE
HISPANIC. AND ABOUT 50% OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS ALTHOUGH WE SUSPECT
THAT PERCENTAGE IS MUCH HIGHER
BECAUSE IT DEPENDS ON HOW. WE
STILL OUT THE LANGUAGE SERVING
MOST OF OUR FAMILIES DO NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH SO I AM
PRACTICING MY SPANISH SO THAT I
CAN COMMUNICATE MORE
EFFECTIVELY WITH THEM AND I GET
BETTER EVERY SINGLE DAY. I WE
WERE CARD AT TO GET OUR
FAMILIES ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
THEIR CHILDREN'S LEARNING. IT
IS OUR GREATEST CHALLENGE AND-
AS A MATTER OF FACT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST- CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM OF
THE ENTIRE DISTRICT SO THAT'S
ONE OF OUR CHALLENGES AT OUR
SITE WE WORK VERY HARD AT THIS
WEEK CAN WITH HER FAMILIES WE
ARE WORKSHOPS WE HAVE COFFEE
CHATS WITH FAMILY DAYS
EVERYTHING WE CAN DO TO GET
THEM IN. BUT IT HIS- CHANGED
THAT KIND OF CAPS AND HE IS A
VERY LITTLE SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH OUR SUPERINTENDENT TO WORK
ON PROVIDING TRANSPORTATION TO
OUR STUDENTS BECAUSE WE'RE THE
ONLY DISTRICT OR THE ONLY
SCHOOL IN OUR DISTRICT THAT HAS
A UNIQUE BOUNDARY LINE AND SO
IT'S AN EQUITY ISSUE FOR
FAMILIES THEY HAVE TROUBLE
GETTING THEIR KIDS TO SCHOOL SO
WE'RE WORKING ON THAT THAT'S
OUR CHALLENGE. BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND ONE OF OUR GREATEST SIX.
IS WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO CREATE A
MATHEMATICS LABORATORY SCHOOL.
WHY WE HAVE A MATH COACH. AND
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO OUR
LABORATORY TO CREATE HIGH
QUALITY TEACHING AND LEARNING
THAT'S RESULTING IN STUDENTS
WHO ARE. HIGHLY COMPETENT
CONFIDENT AND HAVE A POSITIVE
DISPOSITION TOWARDS MATHEMATICS
AND ACTUALLY. THEY ARE
OUTPERFORMING. OUR DISTRICT
AVERAGE SO WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THAT. SO THAT'S A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT WHO WE ARE AND I WANTED
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHY
WE ARE HERE WE WANTED TO SHARE
SOME CONCERNS WE HAVE REGARDING
ASPECT HAS SIXTEEN. AS WELL AS
IDEAS- FOR CHANGING FOR
IMPROVEMENT. SO WELL- EXPECTS
ONLINE ASSESSMENT HAS OBVIOUSLY
MADE- TESTING MUCH MORE
EFFICIENT THAN PREVIOUS TEST.
AND IT IS A LINE TO THE STATE
STANDARDS THERE ARE MANY
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE THAT IT
DOESN'T TRULY ENCAPSULATE WHAT
CHILDREN KNOWING OR ABLE TO DO.
NOR DOES IT SUPPORT TEACHERS IN
UNDERSTANDING WHAT STUDENTS
KNOW FOR THE PURPOSES OF
IMPACTING. THEIR INSTRUCTION OR
BECOMING INTEGRAL PART OF THEIR
INSTRUCTION. AND TO THAT END
THE USEFULNESS OF THE
INFORMATION THAT ASPECT
PROVIDES COMES INTO QUESTION.
UNDERSTANDABLE FOR THE
IMPORTANCE AND NEED FOR
SOMEBODY FROM AN ASSISTANT
ASSESSMENT. HOWEVER THE PURPOSE
OF ASSESSMENT SHOULD BE TO SHOW
ALWAYS GUIDE INSTRUCTION. I'M
WHETHER IT'S SOMEONE EVER
FORMATIVE SUMMATIVE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO GIVE SPECIFIC
INFORMATION TO A TEACHER THAT
WILL BETTER PREPARE THAT
TEACHERS IMPACT HIS OR HER
INSTRUCTION. EVEN IF IT'S IN
THE FOLLOWING YEAR NOT WITH THE
SAME STUDENTS IT DOES GIVE
INFORMATION TO THE CHILD BUT
THE WAY IT'S- DELIVERED NOW IS
NOT VERY USEFUL TO TEACHERS.
THE REPORTS THAT ARE GENERATED
FROM THE RESULTS OF THIS TEST
MIGHT DO NOT PROVIDE CRITICAL
INFORMATION. AND FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE AREA OF MATHEMATICS THE
SCORES ARE BASED ON THREE BANDS
THERE'S CONCEPT AND PROCEDURES
THERE'S PROBLEM SOLVING
MODELING AND DATA ANALYSIS AND
FINALLY THERE'S COMMUNICATING
REASONING. AND BECAUSE THESE
BANDS ARE BROUGHT IN THEIR
CONTENT QUESTIONS ARE OFTEN-
MULTIPLE STANDARDS ARE INCLUDED
IN ONE QUESTION AND AS A RESULT
IT'S DIFFICULT FOR TEACHERS OR
ADMINISTRATORS DETERMINE IF AT
ALL. AND EXACTLY WHAT WHAT IS
WHAT WITHIN THE BAND IS THE
RELATIVE AREA OF STRENGTH OR
WEAKNESS. AND THEREFORE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO FOCUS FUTURE
INSTRUCTION AND FOR PARENTS
THAT SOME TO REPORT ONLY GIVES
GENERAL INFORMATION WITH LINKS
TO PRACTICE TEST. AND AGAIN NOT
pAREAS OF DEFICIT THAT NEED
ADDRESSING. NOT IN TERMS ASMAN
VERY MIGHT BE A LITTLE STEP
TOWARDS FORMATIVE- ASSESSMENT
HOWEVER TEACHERS AREN'T YET
ABLE TO DIRECTLY ACCESS THE
RESULTS AT THIS POINT. TAKE
EITHER INSTRUCTION INSTEAD
THEIR RESULTS ARE GENERATED BY
CLASS AND NOT BY GRADE. AND
THEY'RE GENERATED TO A TESTING
ADMINISTRATOR WHO THEN HAS TO
SORT IT OUT. AND THEN PASS THAT
INFORMATION ON TO THE TEACHERS
WHO THEN HAVE TO LOOK FOR THEIR
OWN STUDENTS AND THEN MAKE
SENSE OF WHAT QUESTIONS THEY
WERE ABLE TO- ANSWER CORRECTLY
AND NOT. OR NOT AT THE FEEDBACK
THAT WE RECEIVED IN OUR
DISTRICT REGARDING THE IN TERMS
IS FAVORABLE ONLY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF PRACTICING THE
TOOLS. ON THE ASPECT BUT HAS
LACKED IN PROVIDING VALUABLE
INFORMATION THAT IS NEEDED TO
GUIDE INSTRUCTION. I TEACHERS
ALSO REPORT THAT. QUESTIONS CAN
BE CONFUSING AND AN EXAMPLE IN
THIRD GRADE AND WHAT IS THE
LEAST TOLD NUMBER THAT CAN BE
ROUNDED TO FORTY. SO IT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE AT ONE OF
OUR HIGHEST PERFORMING SCHOOLS
IN OUR DISTRICT. HER PERCENT
THE KIDS MISS THIS QUESTION.
HOWEVER MULTIPLE OTHER MATTERS
STUDENTS WERE SHOWING
PROFICIENCY IN IT SO WE REALLY
BECAME OF AT AT. A QUESTION
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE OF THE TEST.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IN THAT
CIRCUMSTANCE IS THAT WE START
TEACHING TO THE TEST. AND NOT
SOMETHING THAT WE WERE HOPING
TO GET AWAY FROM WITH THE
PREVIOUS. MORE MY THERE'S A
REPORTING THAT. THE SAME
QUESTION APPEAR IN THE ASP HERE
AFTER YEAR WHICH I THINK I
DON'T BELIEVE WAS THE ORIGINAL
INTENT OF THE S. BACK. AND I
SAID I THINK YOU MENTIONED
BEFORE MAKE IT- YOU KNOW THE
PURPOSE OF COMMON CORE WAS TO
REALLY GET OUR KIDS TO
COLLABORATE NEST RICH DEEP RICH
PROBLEM SOLVING TASKS AND HAVE
COMMUNICATION BUT THEN
ULTIMATELY THEY'RE ASSESSED IN
A DIFFERENT WAY. SO THERE'S
LESS TIME ON THAT COLLABORATION
AND MORE TIME ON PRACTICING FOR
THAT TEST. AND FOR US CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY FOR OUR STUDENTS
AND TAKING THE TEST IS A HUGE
CONCERN- THERE'S GROWING
ATTENTION AND FRANKLY I NEED TO
ENSURE THAT OUR STUDENTS HAVE.
EQUITABLE ACCESS. TO EDUCATION
OPPORTUNITY EQUITY DOESN'T MEAN
THAT EVERYBODY IS EQUAL RATHER
IT MEANS THAT STUDENTS GET WHAT
THEY NEED. SO MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS ARE EXPECTED TO TAKE
THE ASPECT BEFORE THEY BECOME
FLUENT ENGLISH SPEAKERS. AND
WHICH ONLY REALLY ASSESSES
THEIR LANGUAGE ACQUISITION
AUTHOR UNDERSTAND THE CONTENT
WE DO APPRECIATE THE
ACCOMMODATIONS- THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THIS TEXT TO SPEECH
FOR EXAMPLE OR THE POP UP
GLOSSARIES. HOWEVER THESE ARE
NOT YET UNIVERSAL'S TOOLS FOR
ALL STUDENTS AND THEIR YET TO
BE GIVEN IN ITS ENTIRETY IN THE
STUDENTS HOME LANGUAGE.
ADDITIONALLY THE CONTEXT OF
SOME THE QUESTIONS WHILE THEY
ARE REAL WORLD AND WE DO
APPRECIATE THAT AND SLEEPY. AND
DATE DEPT THEY SOMETIMES FALL
OUTSIDE THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR
STUDENTS AND POVERTY FOR
EXAMPLE IN FIFTH GRADE
MATHEMATICS ASSESSMENT STUDENTS
ARE ASKED TO PLAN A DAY AT THE
FAIR. AND WE AGREED TO KEEP
THIS QUESTION TO ASSESS PREPARE
IMPRIMATUR HOWEVER MANY
STUDENTS HAVE NEVER HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO A FAIR.
AND THEREFORE NO ACCESS TO THE
VERY PREMISE OF THE QUESTION
WHICH THEN MAKES THE QUESTION
IS EQUITABLE FOR ALL STUDENTS.
TO ADD ON OUR IMPROPER STUDENTS
ACCESS TO TECHNOLOGY MAY AND
MANY IF NOT MOST CASES BE
GREATLY LIMITED AND THEREFORE
DEPENDS ON THE FUNDING AT THE
DISTRICT LEVEL OR THE SITE
LEVEL. BECAUSE THE TOOLS ON
ASPECT REQUIRE PRACTICE THIS
ONCE AGAIN. ONCE AGAIN POSES AN
EQUITY ISSUE FOR STUDENTS THIS
IS ESPECIALLY THE CASE WHEN
LOOKING AT A GROWING BODY OF
COMPETING RESEARCH EXAM FINANCE
SCREEN TIME IN THE CLASSROOM.
CAN ACTUALLY BE INHIBITORY TO
STUDENT LEARNING. EXCEPTIONALLY
WELL WELL INTENTIONED S. BACK
DOES BECOME A TEST OF STAMINA.
SPECIFICALLY AT THE ELEMENTARY
LEVEL WE'RE ASKING OUR EIGHT TO
ELEVEN YEAR OLDS TO SPEND FOUR
TO FIVE DATE IS TWO TO THREE.
HOURS EACH DAY TAKING THIS
TEST. RESEARCH SUGGESTS THAT
THE AVERAGE STUDENTS OUR
STUDENTS HAVE A SUSTAINED
ATTENTION SPAN. OF THREE TO
FIVE MINUTES FOR EVERY YEAR
THEY ARE ALIVE SO THE AVERAGE
NINE YEAR OLD IN THIRD GRADE
WOULD HAVE AN- ATTENTION SPAN
BETWEEN TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
MINUTES. IT'S NOT UNTIL SEVENTH
GRADE AT A CHILD AT THE HIGHER
END OF THE NORMAL RANGE WOULD
HAVE ROUGHLY A SIXTY MINUTE
ATTENTION SPAN. AND MAYBE ARGUE
THAT ASPECT ALLOWS FOR TESTING
WINDOW THAT WOULD SHORTEN
TESTING ON A GIVEN DAY HOWEVER
THERE ANY ARE VERY. THERE ARE
MANY INHIBITORY FACTORS THAT
PREVENTS THIS INCLUDING
DISTRICT PASTING CALENDARS
DEVICES ACCESS TO DEVICES AND
THE CHALLENGE OF STOPPING
RETURN ON COMPUTER ADAPTIVE
PORTION OF THE ASSESSMENT. ONE
LAST GOING TO SWITCH OUT HERE.
ONE LAST CONCERN CONSERVING- S.
BACK AND- YES THERE ARE
MULTIPLE DAYS THAT THE TEST IS
ADMINISTERED BUT EACH DAY IS A
DIFFERENT PORTION OF THE TEST
THAT CAN LAST FOR MANY ANYTIME
FROM ONE TO THREE HOURS. AND
FOR EACH PART PORTION STUDENTS
GET ONE SHOT AT IT NOW. FOR
THINGS LIKE THE ACT AND THE SAT
IN THE ELSE AT. THOSE KINDS OF
ASSESSMENT A HOST OF OTHER
STUDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO RETAKE
THE ASSESSMENT AS MANY TIMES AS
THEY LIKE NOW WE'RE NOT
ESPOUSING EIGHT AND ELEVEN YEAR
OLDS TO TAKE FIFTEEN OUR TEST
MULTIPLE TIMES BUT- THIS IS
HIGH TECH HIGH STAKES TESTING.
AND MUCH RIDES ON THESE RESULTS
SO WOULD IT BE GREAT IF WE WERE
ABLE TO PROVIDE FOR OPTIMAL
CONDITIONS TO TRULY ASSESS
PROGRESS OVER TIME. AS TO WHAT
STUDENTS KNOW. NOT IDEAS FOR
IMPROVEMENT AS WE STATED BEFORE
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY PURPOSE AN
IMPORTANT IN MEASURING A
STUDENT'S LEARNING OVER A
YEAR'S TIME HOWEVER. THERE'S
MUCH THAT CAN BE DONE TO YIELD
THE MOST ACCURATE MEASURE.
ADDRESSING THE CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT WE JUST MENTIONED WE
BELIEVE WOULD DEFINITELY WORK
TOWARDS BETTER UNDERSTANDING
WHAT STUDENTS ACTUALLY NO AND
WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO DO.
THERE'S NO DOUBT IN OUR MINDS
THAT THAT THIS HIGH TAKES THIS
HIGH STAKES TEST HAS AT THE
MINIMUM MADE STRIDES TOWARD
TECHNOLOGY THE NEED FOR
STUDENTS TO THINK DEEPLY AND
CRITICALLY. BUT WE WONDER IS
ARE WE REALLY ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTION HERE- TO BETTER
SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS IN
LEARNING AND ASSESSING WHAT
THEY'VE LEARNED. THE PROGRAM OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDENT
ASSESSMENT WHICH IS KNOWN AS
PISA. HAS PROVEN THAT WE HAVE
AS A COUNTRY MADE LITTLE
IMPROVEMENT PRUDENT. SINCE ITS
EXCEPTION IN TO THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND. EVEN WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE COMMON
CORE STANDARDS IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN WHICH ATTEMPTED TO BETTER
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY AND FOR THE JOBS
THAT DEMANDED CRITICAL
THINKING. COLLABORATION
CREATIVITY AND COMMUNICATION WE
STILL HAVE REMAINED STAGNANT
AND FAR. FAR BEHIND DEVELOPED
COUNTRIES YEAR AFTER YEAR. SO
WE KNOW THE WHAT. THAT'S
CLEARLY COMMUNICATED BUT WHAT
WE FELT THAT IS THE HOUSE. THAT
IS THE HOUSE HOW DO WE DEVELOP
OUR TEACHERS AND HIGH QUALITY
RESOURCES. TO SUPPORT LEARNING
THE STUDENTS IN BECOMING THE
CRITICAL THINKING THINKERS AND
PROBLEM SOLVERS FOR THE JOBS
THAT DEMAND THESE VERY SKILLS.
NOW WE KNOW FROM THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF SCHOOL LEADERSHIP
AND FROM EXTENSIVE RESEARCH AND
HOW PEOPLE LEARNED THAT THE
GREATEST IMPACT ON STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT IS THROUGH
EFFECTIVE INSTRUCTION AND
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT THAT'S
BEEN PROVEN. ASPECT HAS MADE AN
ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS THE
FORMATIVE PIECE HOWEVER THIS
MUCH TO BE IMPROVED TO TRULY
INFORM INSTRUCTION. BUT WE'VE
DONE LITTLE TO NOTHING AT THE
NATIONAL OR STATE LEVEL TO
ADDRESS THE INSTRUCTIONAL PIECE.
IF THINK EXTRAORDINARY AMOUNTS
OF MONEY THAT IT COSTS TO
ADMINISTER IT TO ADMINISTER
STANDARDIZED TEST. THAT FOR THE
MOST PART IS SUMMATIVE COULD
INSTEAD BE PUT TOWARDS
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT THAT
TEACHERS CAN ACTUALLY USE AND
ARE HELPFUL AND CAN BE APPLIED
TO PRACTICE. IN IT AND BE PUT
TOWARDS TO SUPPORTING
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING AND
TEACHERS WE COULD IN FACT BE
MAKING A SIGNIFICANT
DIFFERENCE. IN STUDENT LEARNING.
WHEN YOU THE CLIP ART TEACHERS.
IN BECOMING MATHEMATICS AND
LITERACY EXPERTS. WE NEED TO
RAISE THEIR CONTENT AND
PEDAGOGICAL KNOWLEDGE AS WELL
AS OUR KNOWLEDGE OF THE BEST
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICE SO HIGH.
THAT THEY CAN MAKE THE BEST
INSTRUCTIONAL DECISIONS TO
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS IN
OBTAINING THE SKILLS. THAT THEY
REQUIRED FOR THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY. THAT WOULD TRULY BE A
HIGH QUALITY ALIGN
INSTRUCTIONAL SYSTEM. IT TOO WE
ADDRESS THE HOW UNTIL WE GET
BETTER AT THIS PIECE WILL NOT
MOVE THE NEEDLE ON THE STATE
THE NATIONAL OR THE
INTERNATIONAL LEVEL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WELL DONE. OUR NEXT
PRESENTER. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL VICE
CHAIRMAN KILEY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY MY
NAME IS DAVID LAWLER. I TEACH
IN THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN BAKERSFIELD AND I'M
ALSO THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
ASSESSMENT TESTING COMMITTEE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. BUT TODAY I SPEAK
AS AN INDIVIDUAL. WITH TWENTY
SEVEN SCHOOL SITES AND FORTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS THE KERN HIGH
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS THE LARGEST
SINGLE HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
THE STATE. AT MY SITE GOLDEN
VALLEY HIGH WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS. 85% OF WHICH
ARE HISPANIC 90% OF WHICH ARE
SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED. THEREFORE MY
FRUSTRATION WITH THE S. BACK
WAS WITH ITS TEACHER RESOURCES.
THE ORIGINAL ROLL OUT OF THE
DIGITAL LIBRARY WAS MYSTERIOUS
THERE WAS GOSSIP ABOUT A FEW
TEACHERS BEING ABLE TO ACCESS
SOME. DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE
WEBSITE DENSELY PACKED WITH
LESS THAN USEFUL AND LESS THAN
USER FRIENDLY MATERIAL AND
THERE WAS LITTLE TRAINING A
LITTLE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM HENCE. WE WERE
FRUSTRATED THAT WE SHARED OUR
CRITICISM ABOUT THE
DISCONNECTED DATA AND THE
UNCLEAR UNUSABLE LESSON PLANS
ON THE SITE. AND I BELIEVE WE
WERE HURT THE TEACHERS IN THE
CLASSROOM WHO HAD TO USE THIS
SYSTEM- WERE HEARD REGARDING
THE DIGITAL LIBRARY WHAT WE NOW
NEED FROM THE NEW SYSTEM
INCLUDES. A LIST OF SPECIFIC
SKILLS BEING ADDRESSED AT EACH
GRADE LEVEL AND WITH THEIR
RESPECTIVE ALIGNMENT TO THE
COMMON CORE STANDARDS OUR
TEACHERS WERE SO CONFUSED BY
THE DIGITAL LIBRARY WE NEED
MORE SOURCES SOLVE THE- WHIMS
JENNA. ERIN LEE IN THE US BACK
SO HAVE WEBSITE WE CAN HE AND
NAVIGATE WITH SKILLS AND
STANDARDS THAT WERE TESTED WILL
HELP RESOLVE THIS FRUSTRATION.
USABE INTERIM AND FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS DIRECTLY TIED TO
SKILLS AND GRADE LEVELS AS WELL
AND BY USABLE I MEAN TO INFORM
INSTRUCTION. OUR NINTH AND
TENTH GRADE TEACHERS HAD NO
DATA TO ANALYZE ONLY THE
ELEVENTH GRADE TEACHERS TESTING
THE US BACKED IT WITHOUT DATA
ARE NINE TO TENTH GRADE
TEACHERS WERE FLYING BLIND.
ALSO THE OLD DATA WAS NOT
HELPFUL WHEN FOR EXAMPLE
READING RESULTS CAME OUT. BUT
HAD NO INDICATORS FOR WHICH
SPECIFIC READING SKILLS TESTED
MAIN IDEA SUPPORTING DETAILS
INFERENCE. WHEN THE DATA IS
ALIGNED TO COMMON CORE
STANDARDS IT DOES FURTHER
INFORM TEACHERS TO IDENTIFY BUT
ONLY WITH EACH STUDENT NEEDS.
WHAT DIRECTION SCHOOLS CAN MOVE
THEIR GLOBAL INSTRUCTIONAL
PATTERNS IN THEIR CURRICULUM
MAPS. WE ALSO NEED MORE
TRAINING ON THE SYSTEM.
TEACHERS USUALLY RIGHT THERE ON
TEST SO THEY KNOW WHAT THE
INSTRUCTIONAL AND GAME IS GOING
TO BE. A TEACHER VERSION OF THE
S. BACK AND MORE PRACTICE TEST
WILL HELP WITH THAT AND
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL YOUR BILL AB
NINE OH EIGHT ADDRESSES THIS IT
IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. I THANK YOU FOR IT.
IN THE COMING YEARS YOU HAVE
OPPORTUNITY TO THE SMARTER
BALANCED SYSTEM MORE DYNAMIC
WHAT SHOULD IT BE. A MULTI
PURPOSE INSTRUMENT THAT CAN
EMPOWER STUDENTS TO SELF
MONITOR THEIR OWN LEARNING.
INFORM TEACHERS TO ADJUST THEIR
INSTRUCTION ALLOW DISTRICTS TO
MEASURE ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COMFORT LEGISLATORS TURN THE
STATUTES AND COMPLIANCE BASED
ON MY EXPERIENCE. THE DASHBOARD
IS SUFFICIENT FOR GAUGING PUPIL
ACHIEVEMENT THERE FOR
INSPECTION NOT HAVE OR VAL ON
THE DASHBOARD THAT DOES NOW.
YEAH TNA. A THIS CALL. TUNES
WITH IMMENSE DE. RIFT OVERALL
IN HIGH. BUT HIRE YOU ON THE S.
SINCE IT'S NOW LOST IN THE
CROWD OF. GIVING MORE TIME TO
FOR. ON COLLEGE CAREER OF.
STOOD TAKE THE S. BACK IN THE
SPRING WE GET THE RESULTS IN
THE FALL WHEN STUDENTS HAVE
MOVED ON TO ANOTHER GRADE AND
ANOTHER TEACHER THE ASPECT
RESULTS MUST BE DELIVERED IN A
TIMELY MANNER. I HOPE THESE
THREE IDEAS DO STICK WITH YOU
THE ASPECT NEEDS NO MORE WEIGHT
ON THE DASHBOARD. SINCE THE ACT
AND SAT OR NOW IRRELEVANT TO
THE POINT OF EXTINCTION
TEACHERS COULD FOCUS ON THE
EXPECT. WHICH REQUIRES HAVING
ITS RESULTS DELIVERED IN A MORE
TIMELY MANNER CONSEQUENTLY
MEANINGFUL FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENTS ARE NOW MORE URGENT
AND NECESSARY AND IT ALL STARTS
WITH BETTER TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS SO THE SYSTEM ITSELF
IS NO LONGER A BARRIER TO OUR
STUDENTS. BECOMES AN INTEGRAL
EMBEDDED ANCHOR PERHAPS THE
GUIDE POST FOR CALIFORNIANS
ENTIRE LEARNING EXPERIENCE.
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
THANK YOU. IT'S MY A GREAT
PRESIDENT TO ADDRESS- THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION
FOR THIS INFORMATION HERE ON
THE US BACK I'D ALSO LIKE TO
PERSONALLY THANK A TERMINAL
DOWN ON HIS STAFF- FOR THEIR
COMMUNICATION SUPPORT I'M
CHRISTOPHER MORE THE ASSISTANT
SUPERINTENDENT OF EDUCATIONAL
SERVICES FOR THE ELDORADO UNION
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT. I'VE
SERVED IN PUBLIC EDUCATION FOR
OVER TWO DECADES AND I'M A
GRADUATE OF THE CALIFORNIA K.
THROUGH- UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. I
BY THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
TEACH IN URBAN AREAS-
AGRICULTURAL AREAS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IN ADDITION I'VE
BEEN A SCHOOL ADMINISTRATOR IN
PRINCIPLE IN THE BAY AREA THAT
A PLURALITY ASIAN STUDENTS I'VE
ALSO. PRINCE WITH A LARGE
COMPREHENSIVE HIGH SCHOOL WHOSE
BOUNDARY WITH SOBRE AND
RELIABLE FOR THE NINE YEAR I'D
CONSUMER OF IS SERVE. I
DISAGREE SIXTEEN HUNDRED
STUDENTS THAT OUT FOR
COMPREHENSIVE HIGH SCHOOLS
WONDER WHEN DISTRICT FUNDED
PREPARATORY CHARTER HIGH SCHOOL
AND A CONTINUATION OF SCHOOL.
THE PURPOSE OF MY OPENING
STATEMENT IS TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH MY EXPERIENCES
WITH THE ASPECTS SOME JIM
INFORMING ASSESSMENTS.
INCLUDING THE ASPECT TOOLS TO
SUPPORT AND IMPROVE
INSTRUCTIONAL PRACTICES. I
BELIEVE I PROVIDING UNIQUE
ADMINISTRATIVE PERSPECTIVE IN
THAT I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
COMMON CORE STATE STANDARDS AND
THE SHIFT FROM THE CALIFORNIA.
STANDARDS TEST TO THE ASPECT
ASSESSMENTS FROM CONCEPTION TO
PRESS PRESENT AS WAS
REFERENCED- EARLYIN THE
OPENING STATEMENTS. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND IN I
YOU'LL YOU'LL HEAR SIMILAR
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALREADY. BEEN EXPRESSED.
THEREFORE CALIFORNIA UPDATES
CONTENT STANDARDS FOR THE
CHRISTIAN FRAMERS IS MY ROLE TO
PROVIDE THE SUPPORT AND
TRAINING AND RESOURCES NEEDED
NEEDED TO ENABLE OUR TEACHERS
TO IMPLEMENT THE STANDARDS AND
FRAMEWORKS. TO BENEFIT STUDENTS
TO IMPROVE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES
FOR ALL STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR SOCIOECONOMIC SITUATION
THEIR ETHNICITY RACE GENDER
IDENTITY HOME LANGUAGE OR
CITIZENSHIP STATUS. OKAY I
BELIEVE THAT WE ALL AGREE THAT
THE CALIFORNIA ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM SHOULD LEAD TO IMPROVED
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. WITH THAT SAID I
BELIEVE SOME THAT THE CHALLENGE
WE'RE FACING TODAY IS THAT SOME
THE TO THE SUBSTANCE BY NATURE
PROVIDE TEACHERS WITH
INFORMATION ON WHETHER STUDENTS
HAVE CLEARED AND IDENTIFIED
LEARNING BAR BUT THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE CLASSROOM TEACHERS WITH
INFORMATION ON HOW TO GET THE
STUDENTS. OVER THE BAR SO FOR
EXAMPLE IF I WERE TO PUT UP A
HIGH JUMP IN HERE AND I SET THE
STANDARD FOR ALL OF YOU IT'S A
CLEAR FIVE FEET. I HAVE THE BAR
AND IT'S NOW UP TO ME TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO TRAIN YOU
GIVEN YOUR FITNESS LEVELS TO
GET OVER THE BAR. THE
ASSESSMENT ITSELF THE STANDARD
ITSELF DOES NOT TELL ME HOW TO
DO THAT. IN MY OPINION THEN THE
GREATEST CHALLENGE THE US BACK
SYSTEM. HAS HAS BEEN ACTUALLY
THE STATE WIDE OUTCOMES. NOT
SURE THIS WITH YOU BECAUSE IF
WE DO WE IF THE INTENT OF OUR
SYSTEM WAS TO IMPROVE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES FOR ALL
STUDENTS. THEN WHY IS IT THAT
28% ONLY TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT.
OF OUR ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS. ARE
MEETING THE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS FOR MATHEMATICS WHY
IS IT THAT ONLY 21% OF OUR
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS. ARE
MEETING THE STANDARDS FOR
MATHEMATICS THE CALIFORNIA
STANDARDS. AND WHY IS IT THAT
ALL THAT ONLY 20% OF OUR LET
NEXT STUDENTS. ARE MEETING THE
STANDARDS SO. THAT WAS THE BILL
THE SYSTEM WITH THE A PETITION
COME A QUARTER WAS IN CREW WAS
TO CREATE MORE EQUITABLE ACT
OUTCOMES. WE OUGHT TO ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT WERE FALLING-
WERE FALLING SHORT. ON THIS.
I'M NOT BLAMING THE ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM- FOR PRODUCING SUCH
DISPARATE OUTCOMES BY STUDENT
GROUPS. BUT WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE TO OURSELVES BUT IF
THE NEW STANDARDS AND THE
SYSTEM SYSTEM WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE TRANSFORMATIVE. WE HAVE THE
LEAST TO DATE COME UP SHORT.
NOW JOHN HARDY IS ONE OF THE
LEADING EDUCATIONAL RESEARCHERS
IN THE PLANET TODAY. AND HE
EXPLAINS THE TEACHER COLLECTIVE
EFFICACY HAS THE GREATEST
IMPACT ON STUDENT LEARNING. HOW
THE STATE'S IT'S ESSENTIAL TO
HELP EDUCATORS MAKE THE LINK
BETWEEN THEIR COLLECTIVE
ACTIONS. AND STUDENT OUTCOMES
THEY NEED TO HEAR FROM THE
STUDENTS MEAN THE TEACHERS
ABOUT THE STUDENTS LEARNING
THEIR PROGRESS THEIR STRUGGLES
AND THEIR MOTIVATION TO KEEP
LEARNING. TEACHERS NEED TO
EXAMINE STUDENT ARTIFACTS SUCH
AS ASSIGNMENTS TESTS PORTFOLIOS
AND OTHER INDICATORS OFDAILY
PROGRESS WITH ALL THESE
ACTIVITIES THE KEY IS MAKING
THE LINK BETWEEN THE TEACHERS
ACTIONS. AND THE STUDENTS
OUTCOMES EXPLICIT SO THE
TEACHERS UNDERSTAND THAT THE
FACTORS BEHIND STUDENT PROGRESS
ARE WITHIN THEIR COLLECTIVE
SPHERE OF INFLUENCE. HOW DOES
RESEARCH IMPLIES THAT THIS THIS
HEARING TODAY THAT IF THE
ASPECT ASSESSMENTS DO NOT HELP
EDUCATORS MAKE A LINK BETWEEN
THEIR COLLECTIVE CLASSROOM
ACTIONS. AND STUDENT LEARNING
OUTCOMES THINK TEACHERS WILL
NOT KNOW HOW TO ADJUST THEIR
TEACHING PRACTICES IN A WAY
THAT LEADS TO MODIFIED OR
TEACHER ACTIONS TO EXPLICITLY
IMPROVE STUDENT LEARNING
OUTCOMES. WHILE SOME OF
ASSESSMENTS ARE REQUIRED UNDER
ASSET AS WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS SOME ASSESSMENTS FALL
SHORT OF PROVIDING TEACHERS
WITH MEANINGFUL ARTIFACTS TO
JUST CLASSROOM PRACTICE. NO
MORE RECENTLY AS IT'S BEEN
REFERENCE THE S. BACKED INTERIM
ASSESSMENTS HAVE EXPANDED TO
ALLOW TEACHERS MORE FOR.
ASSESSMENTS AND ALLOW TEACHERS
WHICH IS IMPORTANT TO YOU ITEM
ANALYSIS BY STUDENT NAME. WHILE
THE ASPECT INTERMENT
ASSESSMENTS ARE INTENDED TO
LEAD TO IMPROVE TEACHER
COLLECTED ADVOCACY. ELEAZAR ARE
STRUGGLING TO EFFECTIVELY
IMPLEMENT THE ENORMOUS
ESTIMATES DO THE FACT THAT THE
ASSESSMENTS AND TOOLS ON THEIR
OWN ARE NOT INTUITIVE. TO HELLO.
ACCESS THE ONLINE SO. VIEW
STUDENTS RESULTS AND LEARNING
HOW TO ANALYZE OUTCOMES USING
THE ONLINE PORTABLES. WITH
THESE BARRIERS THESE ARE THESE
BERRIES ARE NOT INSURMOUNTABLE
BUT THE REQUIRED DEDICATED
STAFF PAID STAFF TO MANAGE THE
ONLINE REPORTING SYSTEM IN
ORDER TO GENERATE REPORTS AND
REQUIRE THE TEACHERS ARE
PROVIDED WITH TIME TO ANALYZE
AND DISCUSS THE RESULTS. NOW
BEFORE I CAME I MAY TRY
SURVEYED OUR OUR TEACHERS AND
THEY PROVIDED ANECDOTAL
INFORMATION BOX ME THEY REALLY
DO WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING
AND AS EFERENCED EARLIER THE
CALIFORNIA JOSH FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL SECOND- LEVEL. USES
THAT'S BACK RESULTS IN THREE
PLACES ENGLISH MATH AND ON THE
CCI INDICATOR THEY REALLY
WANTED TO THE RIGHT THING AND
THEY'RE FEELING THAT THE PORTAL
ITSELF THE ABILITY TO ACCESS
AND GET REAL TIME. INFORMATION
IS A CHALLENGE SO IF THE
INTERIM ASSESSMENT DATA IS NOT
TIMELY ACTIONABLE AND
INFORMATIVE TO TEACHERS THERE
WILL BE VERY LITTLE CHANGE IN
CLASS FROM PRACTICES. TEACHERS
NEED ACTIONABLE DATA THAT
ALLOWS HIM TO BETTER ANSWER
THESE QUESTIONS. DID THE
STUDENTS GAIN ESSENTIAL
UNDERSTANDING SKILLS HOW DO WE
KNOW HOWCAN WE USE EVIDENCE OF
STUDENT LEARNING TO IMPROVE
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION. PRINCE
AND OTHER SCHOOL INSTRUCTIONAL
MUST ALSO RECEIVED TRAINING ON
PROFESSIONAL DEL DEVELOPMENT ON
THE COLLECTIVE ELLAGIC EFFICACY
POTENTIAL. OF THE ENORMOUS
ESTIMATES TO DATE MANY ALWAYS
INCLUDING MY OWN. HAVE
STRUGGLED TO PROVIDE SUCH TIME
THE ACTUAL FEEDBACK USING THE
INTERIM ASSESSMENTS. THEREFORE
THE TOOLS PROVIDED BY THE STATE
pGOAL FOR OUTCOME. THE THEME OF
TODAY'S HEARING THIS CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT THEREFORE THE
QUESTION IS HOW CAN WE AS A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. IMPLEMENTED ASSESSMENT
MODEL THAT IS VALUED AND
EMBRACED BY TEACHERS BECAUSE IT
PROVIDES TEACHERS WITH DATA
THAT LINK STUDENT LEARNING TO
THE EXPECTED CLASSROOM LEARNING
EXPECTATIONS. SOME OF THOSE
SUCH AS I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
ESTABLISH THE BAR FOR LEARNING
FOR BY GRADE LEVEL BUT SUMMIT
ASSESSMENTS DO NOT EXPLAIN HOW
EVERY STUDENT IS EXPECTED TO
CLEAR THE BAR. ASSUMING WE ALL
AGREE. THAT ASKED THAT THE
ASPECT ASSESSMENTS MEASURE WHAT
WE WANT THE STUDENTS TO BE ABLE
TO KNOWING DO FOR ENGLISH
LANGUAGE ARTS AND MATHEMATICS.
I FEEL WE NEED TO SHIFT THE
CONVERSATION TO HOW TEACHERS
COLLECTIVELY IMPACTS STUDENT
LEARNING TO MEET THE AGREED
UPON LEARNING TARGETS. AS
STATES TO UNDERSTAND COLLECTIVE
IMPACT TEAMS OF TEACHERS NEED
DETERMINE IF USING CLASSROOMS.
POSITIVELY IN STOOD OUTCOMES.
EXAMINING SPECIFIC EVIDENCE OF
STUDENT LEARNING. OUR
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM SHOULD MATTER
MATTER WHAT WE WANT STUDENTS TO
BE ABLE TO GO INTO AND PROVIDE
AN ANSWER RUNNING SO TEACHERS
REFLECT THEIR TALK. TO IMPA
STUDENT LEARNING. I LOOK FOR A
DANCE YOUR RECKON PROVIDE GREAT
SERVICE CITY AND CONCRETE
EXAMPLES GREAT THE IT WAS CSUS.
BUT HONESTLY I THINK YOU MISTER
EITHER MISTER LAW ACTUALLY THE
SAME THING HE JUST SAID IT IN
DIFFERENT WAYS I REALLY DO
BELIEVE THAT THE YOU USED
TEACHER SPEAK YEARS
ADMINISTRATIVE SPEAK- BUT- I
MEAN THAT THAT'S WHAT I HEARD
ACTUALLY I THINK YOU GOT IT.
ALLUDED TO WHAT I'M ALLUDING TO
WE NEED MORE FEEDBACK ON A MORE
IMMEDIATE BASIS THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR NOT JUST AT THE END OF THE
YEAR THAT SUMMIT TO PREVENT
AGAIN- AND HOW DO WE DO THAT.
RIGHT I THINK THAT'S A REAL
NEXT QUESTION FOR THE S. BACK
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM OR- BECAUSE I
WANT TO BE AN ASSESSMENT SYSTEM
NOT A TESTING SYSTEM. AS WE AS
WE MENTION. BUT I THINK IT IS
THE HIGHLIGHT HERE THAT IN
TERMS ARE NOT FORMATIVE. IN
TERM AS A CHUNK OF TIME. A
FORMATIVE CAN BE ON A SPECIFIC
STANDARD. THE MEASURE OF THE
COMMITTEE KNOWS WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT THE RIGHT NOW BUT
I HOPE THEY DO- BUT A BIT AGAIN
FORMERS IS MORE IMMEDIATE IT'S
MORE IMMEDIATE FEEDBACK. IT
COULD BE ON A DAILY BASIS COULD
BE I MET A TEN MINUTE BASIS
RIGHT. ARE THEY ARE ARE THEY
ARE THE MASTERING. THE MATERIAL
AND THEN YOU TALKED ABOUT
ANALYZING THE DATA THAT'S
BECOME VERY DIFFICULT TO HEAR
THIS YOU HAVE TO GO TO FOUR
SITES APPARENTLY. IT WE NEED TO
FIX THAT. HERE'S DON'T HAVE
TIME TO GO TO FOUR SIDES. YOU
KNOW WHAT FIVE CLASSES IN HIGH
SCHOOL MAYBE MAYBE SIX CLASSES
THAT'S- CLOSE TO TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS. HEY UNIFOR WEBSITES
FOR STUDENTS. RIGHT NOT
PRACTICAL. SO WE NEED TO FIX
THAT- AND MAYBE IF SOMEONE FROM
THE S. BACK COULD COME UP AT
ADDRESS THAT IN A MINUTE AND A
MINUTE- BUT AGAIN IT WHAT WHAT.
WHAT I'VE ALSO SEEN A LAST TIME
WE HAD THIS YEAR'S COUPLE YEARS
AGO ACTUALLY OF NONPROFITS AND
ACTUALLY FOR PROFIT COMPANIES
COME UP. R THEY'VE ACTUALLY
CREE. A DEVICE OUTSIDE OF THE
US BACK. THAT IS MORE INTERIM
OR MORE MORE FORMATIVE IN
NATURE. AND THAT THAT SOME
DISTRICTS WERE BUYING THAT WILL
THEY HAVE TO BUY ANOTHER
PRODUCT TO FIGURE OUT. HOW THEY
BEST MEET THE NEEDS. ARE THERE
ARE THE DEMANDS OF THE ASPECTS
SYSTEM SO THAT SHOULD ALL BE
BUILT INTO THE ASPECT THAT
WHOLE SYSTEM SHOULD BE BUILT ON
THE S. BACK. AND THAT'S A
FAILURE A LITTLE BIT FROM YOU
KNOW FROM SACRAMENTO. MAJOR
DISCONNECT- FROM THIS DíAS AND
CLASSROOM THAT'S WHY I'M GLAD
YOU'RE GIVING US. THAT FEEDBACK
AND I'VE- THE BILL OF THE PAST
MCCARTY PUSH THIS YEAR WHAT.
THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
SPECIFICALLY AND IT WAS.
CONTROVERSIAL AND THAT WAS TO
ALLOW THE ACT OR SAT. TO
REPLACE THE US BACK AND THAT'LL
EMIGRATE YOUR BUT WHY MY MAJOR
SUPER DOES HAVE THEIR OWN
REASONS RIGHT THEY HAVE THEIR
OWN REASONS WHY THEY WANT THEY
WANT MORE KIDS IN A COLLEGE
SALIVA. MY MAIN REASON WAS
BECAUSE IT WAS MORE OF A FORMER
TO PRODUCT. HE GIVE THE PSA T.
THE PAC T. AND THAT NINETY.
EIGHTH SOMETIME EIGHT NINE.
TENTH AND ELEVENTH GRADE NINTH
TENTH. EIGHT NINETY TENTH
YOU'RE SO YOU CAN IDENTIFY THE
ACHIEVING GAPS THAT CLOSE AND
THAT'S REALLY. WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW DO WE- CLOSE
THIS ACHIEVEMENT GAPS HOW WE
ENSURE. MASTERY OF STANDARDS.
AGAIN I APPRECIATE THAT YOU
BOTH CAME OUT OF FROM A
DIFFERENT. PERSPECTIVE IT'S
OBVIOUS SOMETIMES AS A AS A
CLASSROOM TEACHER I'M WONDERING
WHAT THEY WANT. ON THE S. BACK.
WHAT DO THEY WANT. BECAUSE THE
QUESTIONS THEY DON'T COME
THROUGH SOME BLOOM'S TAXONOMY
TYPE APPROACH FRIDAY JUST SEEM
LIKE THEY'RE FROM LEFT FIELD
SOMEONE WROTE IT UP THIS WAY.
AND I DON'T CHEN ANY OF YOU
WANT TO COMMENT ON ANYTHING I
SAID. ANY ANY FURTHER THOUGHTS.
WHAT I WILL I WILL TELL YOU
CHAIRMAN I ABSOLUTELY AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU'VE SAID IN TERMS
OF THE FRUSTRATIONS WITH THE
WITH THE ASSESSMENT AND FOR AND
IN THE TRENCHES THAT QUESTION
WHAT IS IT THEY WANT AND THEN
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO DO WITH
THAT. WITH THAT INFORMATION-
ARE THE TWO BIGGEST CONCERNS WE
NEED TIME TO FIGURE THOSE
THINGS OUT AND HOPEFULLY WITH
THE NEW WEB SITES WILL BE ABLE
TO I WILL SAY ONE LAST THING
THOUGH WE ARE LUCKY AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL TO HAVE STUDENTS
WHO ARE SOMEWHAT MORE FLUENT
WITH USING THE COMPUTER BUT THE
DIGITAL NATIVES YOU HEARD OF-
IN PANEL ONE- MY SON IS ONE OF
THOSE HE WAS IN KINDERGARTEN
THE FIRST YEAR CONCORD ROLLED
OUT HE'S ELEVEN HE'S IN THE
SIXTH GRADE. HE HAS FIVE SIX
AND SET OF FRIENDS WHO WOULD
KNOW HOW TO. USE A COMPUTER FOR
A TEST LIKE THIS SO GOD BLESS
YOU IN THE ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
DEALING WITH. A COMPUTER IT'S
ACTED WELL TOO BECAUSE A LOT OF
THE IPAD IN THAT RIGHT. TO
KEYBOARDS GONE FOR THE LITTLE
ONES ARE AT. SOME OF THE PAST
OKAY THANK YOU. AND THEN I TOOK
TO OUR TO OUR PREVIOUS PANEL
THANK YOU AGAIN- AND MAYBE ONE
OF YOU COULD RESPOND TO THIS A
FIRST OF ALL YOU STATED THAT A
NINE YEAR OLD HAS A TWENTY
SEVEN A FORTY FIVE MINUTE.
ATTENTION SPAN IS VERY
INTERESTING. MUCH LONGER THAN
SOME LEGISLATORS I KNOW. BUT I
WILL SAY THIS IS UNIQUE I GOT
IT I GOT YOU LET ME GIVE KUDOS
TO MY COLLEAGUES HERE. WHO HAVE
SAT THROUGH THIS. BECAUSE I
THINK IF YOU YOU KNOW MAYBE IF
YOU HAVEN'T DONE THIS TOO MUCH
YOU WONDER WHAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT RIGHT. AND I UNDERSTAND
THIS I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
THAT MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SAT
THROUGH THIS CONVERSATION
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A- A
VERY BIG CONVERSATION HAVE
BECAUSE IF. YOU KNOW IT IS A
HIGH STAKES TEST WHETHER WE
WANT TO BE OR NOT IT IS. AND SO
WE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
IT RIGHT I THINK THIS
CONVERSATION ABOUT GETTING IT
RIGHT- SO WITH THAT AND- WHICH
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT-
SUMMARIZING THE INFORMATION
YOU. I DON'T I TALK ABOUT
ACCESSING FOR WEBSITES- DO YOU
FIND IT. LET ME THROW QUESTION
DO YOU FIND IT DIFFICULT. TO
CALL THE DATA INTO ONE SPOT SO
YOU CAN IDENTIFY THE IT WOULD.
HOW STUDENTS ARE ACHIEVING. AND
I TALK ABOUT SORTING OUT THE
DATA IN THE INTERIM ACCESS DID
YOU. COULD YOU LOOT ON THAT. I
TOOK SIR THAT OUT WE HAVE-
AGAIN HI SO DISTRICT WE'RE
WE'RE FOLKSINGERS MATHEMATICS
AND SO AS THE PORTALS KEEP
EVOLVING AND CHANGING I GUESS
WE WANT TO BE DO IF WE WANT TO
DO THE RIGHT THING SO WE'VE WE
HAVE TO TRY TO CREATE THIS
BACKWARDS MAPPING PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT MODEL SO YOU'RE THE
SECOND REASON OF A CONTRACT
WITH THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION I HAVE TO
HIRE STAFF TO COME OUT TO OUR
HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT I HAVE TO
TRAIN THE TEACHERS WE TRY TO DO
A TRAIN THE TRAINER MODEL SO
THEY CAN JUST BASICALLY
UNDERSTAND HOW TO USE THE
PLATFORM. THEN YOU HAVE TO TAKE
THAT INFORMATION IDENTIFY I
TIME WITHIN THE PROFESSIONAL
YOU KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE REALLY
REALLY SOME OF YOUR
PROFESSIONAL LEARNING
COMMUNITIES TO THEN TRY TO
UNPACK- HOW TO GET CAUGHT UP TO
ANALYZE IT AND USE IT AND THEN
THE PORTAL ALTHOUGH IT'S
IMPROVING HAS CHANGED AND SO
THEN THE TEACHERS THIS YEAR WHO
HAD BEEN TRAINED IN A
PARTICULAR WAY OF DOING IT HOW
DID WHEN THE PROCESS OF
RETRAINING THEM AND SO I JUST
DON'T WANNA THERE'S- THERE ARE
COSTS AND EFFORTS AROUND
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ACCESS THIS INFORMATION AND
IT'S IT IS A REAL BARRIER SO
IT'LL- TRYING TO GET IN. CAUSES
LOS UP OUR STUDENTS ARE NOT
LEARNING NOT MEETING THE
STANDARDS EVEN THOUGH THE TOOLS
ARE IMPROVED I'M NOT DENYING
THAT THERE ARE LINE I'VE BEEN
SYSTEM WORST STRUGGLE THING OUR
TEACHERS. MEETING WAIT THAT ONE
TIME IN OUR- SO THEY CAN.
HAVING QUESTIONS ABOUT DO WE
TO. THESE ON THAT. TEACH
SPENCER A WAY THAT STUDENTS
ABLE TO PASS THIS EXAM WHAT.
LET ME LET ME. LET ME PROJECT
ON THAT SO IT'S TWENTY. SHE THE
ABLE TO HIT A BUTTON. HAVE THEY
INFORMATION. WELL BECAUSE THE
INFORMATION AND MY OPINION A
MALE THAT OTHER CONSORTIUM
SPEAK TO THAT THE INFORMATION
IS PROPRIETARY SO MUCH IN OUR
OWN LIVES I THINK WE HAVE
USERNAME AND PASSWORD FATIGUE.
AND EVERYTHING THAT WE
SUBSCRIBE TO. SERVE BECAUSE
THIS PROPRIETARY INFORMATION
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A DESIGNATED
PERSON FIRST OF ALL I'D-
JENNIFER WHO HAS ACCESS. TO THE
INFORMATION AND AT WHAT LEVEL
THAT ACCESS THE INFORMATION.
THEN YOU HAVE TO HAVE STAFF
PREPARED TO CREATE GROUPS
BECAUSE IT ACTUALLY ONE WOULD
LOOK AT GROUPS OF STUDENTS AND
DO THIS ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS.
YOU FIRST THEN HAVE TO ASK THE
TEACHERS WHAT'S UP A GROUP THAT
YOU WANT. AND THEN SOMEBODY
CENTRALIZED LOCATION HOUSE AND
THEN GENERATE THOSE GROUPS AND
THEN ONCE THOSE GROUPS ARE
CREATED YOU HAVE TO IDENTIFY
TEACHER LEADER OR COULD BE A
TOW SO. SHE TRANSNATIONAL SIMON
TO THEN GO OUT AND FACILITATE
THE DISCUSSIONS. I JUST IT'S
NOT AS EASY AS WE JUST MADE IT
AVAILABLE AND THEN YOU'RE ABLE
TO MAKE SENSE OF THE
INFORMATION. THERE'S THERE
NEEDS TO BE LEADERSHIP IN
ORGANIZATION ABOUT WE'RE NOT
LIKE WILL SHOULD BE THAT EASY-
I WOULD ARGUE THAT THAT IT THAT
IT SHOULD BE THAT EASY BUT I'D-
IF YOU KEEP. THE GOOD LIKE THE
ONE WEEK WHY ARE WE IN A
CONSORTIUM THAT WE WERE PART OF
THIS. YOU KNOW BODY THIS
GOVERNMENTAL BODY WHERE WERE
YOU KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ANSWER THE WIRING A CONSORTIUM
WE CAN'T ACCESS THIS
INFORMATION WILL NOT ONLY THAT.
THERE'S A HUNDRED ANDEIGHTY AS
WELL I'M HOLDING UP THIS IS THE
MEASURE THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL
NUMBER OF A SET IN ASSESSMENTS
THAT AVAILABLE FOR MATHEMATICS
AND IT'S HARD TO SEE BUT-
THERE'S A HUNDRED EIGHTY SCHOOL
DAYS IN A GIVEN YEAR. SO THEY
ALSO BECOMES QUESTION FROM THE
GO SUPPORT PEDAGOGICAL
PERSPECTIVE. HOW MANY DAYS OF
THE HUNDRED EIGHTY THAT WE-WE
GONNA COMMIT. TO PROCTOR IN
THESE. THESE EXACT. INSTEAD OF
GETTING OFF SUBJECT INSTEAD OF
ALLOWING THE TEACHERS. TO TEACH
THE- OKAY BORDER. TOWN THE IT I
DON'T. THINK WHAT WHAT IS IT
THAT WE ARE. DURING WHAT IS
WHICH TO CALL WHAT IS THE WE
WANT STUDENTS TO WHAT. AND WE
GOT TO. AND THEN. AND IF I CAN.
HAVE THE- IT IS SUBSTANTIAL AND
AN EX IT ALTHOUGH IS A GOOD
THING IT ALLOWS TEACHERS RIGHT
SPECIFIC THINGS WANT TO LOOK AT
BUT IT BUT IT THERE A LOT HERE
SO AND- MISS HOMES. WELL THAT
REALLY. AND ABSOLUTELY I MEAN
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT TO USE THE
INFORMATION TO ACCESS THE
INFORMATION TO MAKE IT USER
FRIENDLY FOR TEACHERS TO MAKE
SENSE OF IT AND THIS IS THE
INTERIM YES. UNDER RIGHT AND IN
YOU POINTED OUT IN TERM DOESN'T
NECESSARILY MEAN FORMATIVE A
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT SHOULD
INFORM IT'S IN THE ROOT OF THE
WORD IT SHOULD INFORM
INSTRUCTION AND IT'S JUST NOT
DOING THAT AT THIS POINT LEAST
THAT'S THE FEEDBACK THAT WE'RE
GETTING IN OUR DISTRICT AND
FROM DIFFERENT SITES DIFFERENT
TACK GRADE LEVELS THAT WHAT IS
BECOMING MORE PRONOUNCED IS
THAT WHEN YOU FINALLY GET TO
OKAY THIS MANY KIDS MISS THIS
QUESTION WHAT IS IT ABOUT THE
QUESTION OR IS TO THE CHILDREN
TRULY UNDERSTAND THE CONTENT OR
DO THEY UNDER. NOT UNDERSTAND
THE WAY THE QUESTION WAS ASKED
AND THAT'S A DIFFERENT QUESTION
I MEAN WE SHOULD BE FOCUSING ON
MAKING SURE CHILDREN UNDERSTAND
THE STANDARDS WE SHOULD MAKE BE
MAKING SURE THAT- OUR TEACHERS
ARE EMPOWERED WITH HIGH QUALITY
INSTRUCTION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
MEET THE STANDARDS WE SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT THE STANDARDS IS A
FLOOR NOT THIS THE CEILING. AND
INSTEAD FOCUS NOW IS GOING TO
THE LÏNG THE TASK IS HOW YOU
TO MAKE SURE A PASS THIS
QUESTION TO. AND I THINK
SOMETHING THAT. WE'RE MISSING
THE POINT THERE. OKAY SO SUIT
HELL HELPS LEAD QUESTION HOW
LONG HOW MANY DAYS A YEAR DOES
IT TAKE YOU TO ADMINISTER THE
TEST. WILD THAT. WE CAN IN. TWO
WEEKS WE SPENT TWO WEEKS AMEND
DAYS TEN SCHOOL THAT. OF THE
YEAR YEAH TEN DAYS AT THE END
OF THE YEAR AND THAT'S THE
OTHER THING TO IMAGINE PERCENT
OF YOUR YEAR WELL AND ON TOP OF
YOU MENTIONED BEFORE. AT THE
YOU KNOW IF IN TERMS TO THEN
ADD THAT ON THAT SPENDING A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF YOUR
TESTING ON TOP OF DISTRICTS
THAT THEIR OWN ASSESSMENTS
HEATED TO WHICH IS A PROBLEM
THAT I KNOW THAT'S OUTSIDE OF
THE REALM. I'VE GOT A LOADED
QUESTION FOR YOU. ARE YOU'RE
DISTRICTS ASSESSMENTS MORE
INFORMATIVE TO YOUR TEACHERS.
THEN THE ASPECT. WELL YES
ABSOLUTELY. YEAH ABSOLUTELY DO
THEY COMPORT WITH THE ASPECT
YES MA'AM. WHAT YOU'VE DONE AND
IN IT INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR
SOME PRODUCT THROUGH US BACK IF
HE'S CREATED YOUR OWN FORMATIVE
ASSESSMENT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
WE DID PROBLEM I HAVE WITH A
CHALLENGE I HAVE WITH AS THAT
MEANS THERE'S ONE THOUSAND
pACCOUNTING DIFFERENCE AFTER
SPENDING TIME CREATING THEIR
OWN ASSESSMENTS NOTHING WE
SPENT ABOUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
ON THAT ABOUT TEN YEARS AGO.
DOING THAT I THINK THEY WERE
GOING PLAN BECAUSE THE S. AND
FULLY DEVELOPED HAD GONE ONLINE
AND USE IT WE'RE GETTING READY
FOR IT I WAS ONE OF THEM. RIGHT
ALL THEY THAT WHEN TEACHERS
CREATE ON ASSESSMENTS THE LEVEL
OF LEARNING FOR TEACHERS GOES
WAY WAY UP. RIGHT NOW. THEY
HAVE TO DECIDE HOW MUCH FAITH.
THEY'RE PUTTING IN ON AS BACK
AND THE ITEMS THE TEST ITEMS IN
THIS BACK. WHEN TEACHERS
KNOWLEDGE IS NOT THAT HIGH
THEY'RE GOING TO THEY'RE GOING
TO DO IT MOST TEACHERS DO THEY
TEACH TO THE TEST THEY- AND SO.
WHAT WE BEHOLDING TO WE'RE
BEHOLDING TO THE TEST FOR SURE
BUT WE'RE ALSO HOLDING TO OUR
KIDS IN THE NEXT GRADE LEVEL
RUSSELL BEHOLDING TO THOSE KIDS
WHEN THEY GET TO MIDDLE SCHOOL.
WERE ALSO THE WHOLE TO GET
THESE KIDS READY FOR HIGH
SCHOOL AND WE'RE ALSO HOLDING.
FOR THESE KIDS TO BE ABLE TO BE
ADULTS AND BE ABLE TO MOVE
THROUGH A MATHEMATICAL SOCIETY.
SO WHEN TEACHER KNOWLEDGE COMES
UP WHEN THEY'RE CREATING
THEY'VE THEY'VE THEY'VE TO
PROFESSIONALS ON WE DO IS A LOT
AROUND EIGHT. HOW CAN WE
MEASURE. WHAT WE WANT TO GET TO
KNOW NOW WEEK WE GO FROM THE
STANDARDS OF COMP COMMON CORE
STAND AS WE LOOK AT IT ME. WE
MEASURE ALL THE TIME. THAT'S
PROGRESSION OVER TIME. SO THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER OF. ANY OTHER
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. DOCTOR WEBER. YES
THE THANK YOU AB BOTH FOR BOTH
PANELS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THE INFORMATION THAT YOU'VE
GIVEN US OBVIOUSLY YOU'VE DONE
QUITE A BIT OF THINKING ABOUT
THE SUBJECT ITSELF- I PROBABLY
I THINK I WAS PROBABLY THE ONLY
ONE ON THE IN THE ASSEMBLY WHEN
WE DID THIS WHEN WE STARTED
THIS SO SMART BALANCE AND- WE
PUT IN TWO BILLION DOLLARS SO I
REMEMBER- AT THE- EDUCATION
OMMITTEE TO BASICALLY GET TO
ADDRESS. PARTICULAR ISSUE I'M
WONDERING THAT WE WAIT A TWO
BILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I'M HEARING IN
THE MEN'S- DON'T SEEM LIKE WE
MOVED VERY FAR- WE SEEM TO BE
SAYING BUT WE WERE OF WHAT IS
WAS IN TWENTY THIRTEEN- WHEN WE
PUT TWO BILLION DOLLARS HE SAID
IF IT FILE THE SMART OF BALANCE
OR IS. COMMON CORE WAS TO BE A-
IT'S GOING TO BE. SOME OUT OF
THE AFTER LIMITED TRAINING.
REMEMBER THE AND WE GAVE TO
BILLION INTO THE BUDGET THE-
YEAR CARING WHAT THIS. YEAR WE
PUT IN BUT WE PUT A LOT OF
MONEY. INTO OF STAFF
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS- WE'VE BEEN
MENTIONED THE NEED FOR THE-
UNIVERSITIES TO- CHANGE THEIR
TEACHER TRAINING. EDUCATION
PROGRAM SO THAT WE WOULDN'T FOR
BE FOREVER. IN THIS MODE THE
WE'RE IN NOW TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO GET THERE HOW TO.
HELP KIDS TO SUCCEED. AND
WHETHER NOT ARE MET THAT AND
ARE THINGS THAT WE'RE USING TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS THAT WITH
THE EYES YOU MENTION WE SET THE
STATE ANOTHER QUESTION IS HOW
DO WE GET THE KIDS TO THE
STANDARD. AND WHICH BECOMES THE
REAL CHALLENGE WHICH IS REALLY
THE TEACHING THAT OCCURS MUCH
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE. AND
THAT HAS BECOME OBVIOUS THE
SHOP AND I'M- I'M I'M I'M HAPPY
THAT I'M THE FOLKS. AT YEAH
THAT'S A REAL CHALLENGE IS
REALLY NOT SO MUCH. A DEFINED
UNDER ITS AND WHAT HAVE WE DONE
AND I KNOW ONE. THING WE WHAT
WE WANT EVERYONE ALL THE
THINGS. HOW GET KIDS THERE AND
ONE OF THE. WE NEED TO. THE
STAFF THE ELEMENTARY FOR TO
HELP THEM GET THE BECAUSE THEY
IS A NEW WAY OF IS AN METHOD
THIS A NEW THAT WOULD LOOK FOR
AND OF WHAT WEEKS FROM I
PEOPLE'S A PART OF THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO BE STAFF
DEVELOPMENT AND TRAINING SO I'M
NOT SURE IF WE'VE DONE ENOUGH
OF THAT- I'M NOT SURE WHERE OUR
UNIVERSITIES ARE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW THE GENERAL THINKING IS
THAT THEY'RE THE ONES TRAINING
OUR TEACHERS EIGHTY SOME
PERCENT OF ALL OF OUR TEACHERS
COME FROM THE C. ISSUE SYSTEM.
SO WHETHER NOT ART TEACHER IT
PROGRAMS HAVE ADAPTED TO IT I'M
NOT REALLY SURE OF I KNOW WHEN
I WAS AT THE UNIVERSITY I DON'T
I DON'T SEE THE UNIVERSE IS
RESPONDING A LOT TO OUR STUFF
ME THEY DO IN TERMS OF WHAT
THEY RIGHT NOT NECESSARILY IN
HOW THEY HANDLED THIS TO
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT SEEM TO
BE THAT. BEN FOR LAST EIGHTEEN
YEARS SO THIS A REAL CHANCE AT
MY OTHER FIRST RATE COMES IN
THE FACT THAT. WE'VE DONE A
LITTLE TO LOOK AT THE SYSTEM
AND EXIST BECAUSE MOST OF OUR
CHALLENGES K. TWELVE. I MEAN
CASE SIX K. SEVEN. BECAUSE IF
YOU GET A- FUNCTIONING AND
DOING WHAT YOU WANT IN THE
FIRST FIVE OR SIX YEARS. IS TO
HELP YOU KNOW I'S A SLIDE DOWN
HILL PRETTY MUCH BECAUSE- AT
THAT POINT IS REALLY JUST A
SIMPLE YOU. BASICALLY
OVERLAYING THIS CONTENT OVER
THE SKILLS THAT THE KIDS HAVE
DEVELOPED IN TERMS OF. HOW THEY
THINK AND WHAT THEY SEE. SO I
BIG FAILURE LIES IN K. FIVE.
YEAH AND THEN IT JUST
MULTIPLIES AFTER THAT IF YOU
DON'T GET IT DONE. SO I'M NOT
SURE WHETHER WHAT WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN TERMS OF. ENSURING THAT
THAT FIRST FIVE OR SIX YEARS
MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND IT
SHOULD BE MAKING A DIFFERENCE
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE SEE WHAT WE
WANT. AND WHAT THE NOT DONE THE
NECESSARY STAFF DEVELOPMENT.
TRAINING BUT IT IS. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT
WE CAN WE CAN DEVELOP WE CAN.
ADAPT ALL THE STUFF THAT WE GET
WE CAN CHANGE THIS THAT AND THE
OTHER. BUT IF WE DON'T. YOU OUT
KEY THE TERM. ON THE- KING AT
KIDS WHOSE. WHO WOULD 2020%
TALLER PERFORMANCE WHICH
BECOMES ARE. A REAL CHALLENGE
TO SEE WHETHER NOT EVERYBODY'S
GETTING THIS CURRICULUM- THAT
BECOMES A MAJOR CHALLENGE THAT
SO THEY ARE YOU KNOW HOW DO YOU
TURN THOSE KIDS ON. OW DO YOU
HELP THOSE TEACHERS UNDERSTAND
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO. TO RELATE
TO THOSE STUDENTS. TO MOTIVATE
THEM TO ACCEPT THE TO BASICALLY
MEET THOSE CHALLENGES AND THAT
IT THERE. AND WE CAN'T WAIT TO
THE END OF THE YEAR. YEAH ON.
TO YOU GO THROUGH THIS I'M HAVE
BEEN IN CLASSROOMS WHERE.
TEACHERS ARE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN
DOING THIS AND THEY'RE PROBABLY
NOT DOING AS MUCH OF THE-
MENTAL AT. OF GYMNASTICS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT THEY
HAVE TO LOOK UP EVERY TEST
SCHOOL WE HAVE TO FIND. THE
NAME OF THE PERSON. FIND AT
EVERY LITTLE. THERE THEY
SOMEHOW ANOTHER FROM HOME. IN
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE GETTING.
IN THIS. BEGIN POST. WHETHER
THE KEY IS GET. THIS OF.
THINKING THAT ARE. SO I THINK.
WHAT WE TO PUT. BECAUSE ALL.
ALL OF. HIM TO BOOK. AND YOU
BEGIN TO DO IT AND THEN YOU
START QUESTIONING YOURSELF. AND
EVERYTHING YOU KNOW YOU HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE COMPUTER. AND
FIND IT IF IT'S REALLY REALLY
RIGHT. IT IS TAKE YOUR LIFETIME
AND YOU WON'T GET VERY FAR
BECAUSE YOU BEGIN TO RELY UPON
THAT RATHER THAN WHAT YOU KNOW.
AND HOW TO ASSESS WHAT'S GOING
ON SO. SO I YOU KNOW I BECOME
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THERE ARE
SOME FOLKS WHO. WHO REALLY KNOW
THIS STUFF. WHO REALLY KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE SOME EXAMPLES OF
SOME SCHOOLS WHO REALLY ARE
SUCCESSFUL. I WAS READING ONE
IN SAN FRANCISCO YOU PROBABLY
HEARD THE ONE IN SAN FRANCISCO
WITH THESE KIDS. IN MATH I JUST
BLOWING THE TOPS OFF. SO THE
QUESTION THEN BECOMES. YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE THEY DOING. AND WHAT
WE READ IN THE COMPUTER
PRINTOUT. VERSUS LOOKING AT THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE SUCCESSFUL. YOU
KNOW WE FIND THAT TO BE TRUE A
LOT IN THE FOURTEEN SCHOOLS
AROUND HERE WITH THESE KIDS IS
BLOWING THE TOP OFF OF THE MAP.
AND SO. LOOKING AT WHAT WHAT'S
WRONG WITH THESE. NORMALLY BE
FAIL BUT ARE NOT. YOU KNOW. AND
FIGURE NOT BECAUSE WE SET THE
STANDARD WE'VE GOT THE MATERIAL
WE WANT THEM TO LEARN. BUT WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW DO YOU
RELATE TO THE STUDENTS HOW DO
YOU MOTIVATE THE STUDENTS TO
LEARN. HOW DO YOU GET THE
MOVIE. IN AND THAT'S THAT THAT
IN ITSELF IS THE ART OF
TEACHING. AND SO I DON'T WANT
TO BE VALUE WHAT I. CHOOSE
HAVE. AS THE DATA WELL THE TO
HOPEFULLY LOOK INTO AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON WELL WE
SEEM TO READ AMOUNT OF STUDIES.
I MEAN I THINK THOSE THINGS ARE
IMPORTANT IF YOU GET TO A POINT
WE RUNS A WALL AND YOU JUST
CAN'T. SEEM TO MOVE IT YOU WANT
TO FIGURE. IT IS. BUT
OFTENTIMES WEEDS SECOND GUESS
OUR FOLKS ABILITY TO DO IT. AND
AS A RESULT WE COMPLICATE
TEACHING. SO A BIG. A BY IN
SOME. AND ONE TEACHING BECOMES
ROLLED. IT IS D. IS GOING TO
DIP KIDS COME WITH ABILITY. MAY
LOSE THIS PAST IN THIS DESIGN.
AND IT'S AND IT'S A BIT KEY TO
GET. ON BECAUSE KID'S. HAS COME.
TO THE SUBJECT MATTER. SO I'M-
HOPING THAT. THAT ALL OF THE-
BILL IN THE DOT. WE SPENT WE
HAVE DONE THE- THAT WOULD THAT
THIS. SUPPORTED WITH. WE REALLY
SUPPORTS US IN IN THE IN A WAY
BUT DOES NOT TAKE AWAY. THE
HUMAN ELEMENT OF TEACHING. THAT
THIS IS A PASSION THAT THE THAT
YOU CAN REACH THESE KIDS AND
THAT OTHER PEOPLE HAVE. AND
THAT WE BEGIN TO LOOK AROUND
BECAUSE LIKE I SAY EERY NOW
AND THEN I RUN ACROSS. SOMEONE
WHO'S DONE IT YEAH THE WHOLE
SCHOOL LIKE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M DETERMINED TO GET THERE
TO SEE THE SCHOOL. WHERE THEY
JUST BLOWN THE STOCKS OFFER
MET. IN THIS IN THIS POOR
NEIGHBORHOOD OF KIDS NORMALLY.
BE AND- WE TO FIGURE THAT OUT
AND LET THAT MOTIVATES
SOMETIMES OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
PRINCIPLES TO. TO DO SOME
THINGS OR SOME OF THESE
INSTITUTES THAT LIKE JOE
JOHNSON OTHERS ONE WHICH REALLY
FOCUSON UNDERPERFORMING
SCHOOLS. AND FIGURE OUT WHAT
THESE FOLKS ARE DOING. AND DO
THAT BECAUSE- WE'VE ALREADY
SPENT WHAT IS A SIX SEVEN YEARS
NOW WOULD SMARTER BALANCED AND
COMMON CORE AND OTHER THAN
THAT. AND BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS AND THAT'S OKAY I
MEAN YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING. STAFF DEVELOPMENT
TRAINING. BUT AS I LISTEN TO
THIS IT JUST SEEMS LIKE IT'S
EXHAUSTING. OF YOU KNOW TO GO
HOME TO GET IN THE CLASSROOM. I
MEAN YOU KILL YOURSELF BRING
THE STUFF ALL DAY LONG. AND
THEN YOU AND THEN YOU REALIZE
YOU SPENT DAYS. DOING THIS AND
NOT DOING WHAT YOU KNOW SHE
SHOULD. IN TERMS OF THE
CLASSROOM SO. I HOPE WE COME IN.
ABOUT THAT YOU KNOW BECAUSE.
TEACHING IS A PASSION. YOU KNOW
IN THOSE DO IT DO IT WELL. AND
I'VE SEEN. WHO WANTED BECAUSE
UP IN ALL THE OTHER STUFF. AND
GET TO THE QUESTION OF. HOW DO
YOU KNOW THIS KID PICKED UP
THIS TOPIC HOW DO YOU KNOW THEY
REALLY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
AND HOW AND YOUR ASSESSMENT AS
A TEACHER. TO KNOW THAT THEY'VE
THAT THEY'VE ACTUALLY MASTERED
THIS. AND THAT YOU CAN LAYER IT
AND BUILD ON SOMETHING ELSE IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND
SELF. I DON'T KNOW I JUST GOT
TIRED. OF BEING VERY EXHAUSTED
AND I'VE TALKED TO FORTY YEARS
AND I THOUGHT LORD BY TO DO ALL
THAT. I'M NOT SURE AB ONE EVER
TEACH THE CLASS. BUT WITHOUT
THE PASSION. IN THE INNATE
ABILITY OF A GOOD TEACHER TO
FIGURE OUT WHEN THE BILL WHEN
THE LIGHT GOES OFF. OKAY THANK
YOU DOCTOR ROBERT I AGREE YOU
CAN'T STANDARDIZED GOOD
TEACHING. BECAUSE IT'S AN ART.
AND EVERYBODY BRINGS YOUR SKILL
SET AND THEIR PERSONALITY. TO
MATCH THOSE. THAT EXIST IN ANY
CLASS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE DO HAVE
STANDARDIZED TEST. AND THAT'S
THAT'S A CHANNEL HERE I. KNOW
YOU. WE SHOULD GIVE US HOPE.
THAT HER BRAG. AFTER SCHOOL
AND- VERY DIVERSE SCHOOL AND IN
PARTICULAR THEY ARE FOCUSED ON
MATH AND IN PARTICULAR THEY DO
A VERY GOOD JOB ON MASS SO GO
AHEAD AND DO A TWO THREE MINUTE
ADVERTISED. WE'D LIKE TO INVITE
YOU TO OUR SCHOOLS COME JOIN US
AND ASKING DIEGO. AND YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND THAT'S WHY
A PART OF WHAT MIKE SAID WAS
ARE WE ASKING THE RIGHT
QUESTION. YOU KNOW BECAUSE WE
DO KNOW THAT AND THE MOST
IMPACTFUL- AND- MEASURE OF
STUDENT SUCCESS IS THE
INSTRUCTION AND HOW THE
INSTRUCTIONS FORM BASED AND
FORMATIVE ASSESSMENT. I KNOW
THAT FROM THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF SCHOOL LEADERSHIP-
AND WE ARE AS A COUNTRY WE ARE
EIGHT IN MATHEMATICS WHERE
THIRTY SIX. THIRTY AND WE HAVE
COVERAGE THERE FOR SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF PIZZA. SO I WANT
TO ADDRESS IS THE MATH REAL
QUICK- YOU KNOW WHAT OF ONE OF
MY MATH HERE SAID IT BEST. YOU
KNOW. FIFTY BOB. HOW WE TEACH
BUT IS COMPETE HOW WE NEED TO
TEACH NOW. COMPETES WITH TWELVE
SIX TWELVE YEARS OF LEARNING
MATHEMATICS RIGHT AS LEARNERS
OF MATHEMATICS AND AS TEACHERS
HOW MANY YEARS ON TOP OF THAT
WE HAVE BEEN TEACHING
MATHEMATICS SO TO YOUR POINT IT
DOES TAKE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT AND THERE WAS MONEY
PUT TOWARDS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT WHEN COMMON CORE.
WAS IMPLEMENTED BUT IT WASN'T
ENOUGH AND IT REALLY DOES TAKE
CONTINUOUS PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT ONGOING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
BECAUSE IT TAKES A LOT CHANGE
THE WAY WE INSTRUCT I'M ALSO
ACCORDING TO PEACE ABOUT 50% OF
THE ADULTS COUNTRY DON'T
BELIEVE THEY'RE GOOD AT MATH.
AND ACTUALLY I'VE DONE THAT.
CHECK THE CONSULTING FOR TO
MALCOLM MY AS WELL AND WE'VE
TALKED OVER THE- IN
INTERNATIONALLY AS WELL. AND IN
SACRAMENTO YES WE DID- AND
THAT'S A TRUE STATISTICS AND
IT'S OUR EXPERT IN ITS OUR
EXPERIENCE AS WELL. AND WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING TO CHANGE THAT
BUT IT DOESN'T HAPPEN THAT
QUICKLY SO WANTED TO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I AM ABLE TO DO IT
MY SCHOOL BECAUSE I'M A TITLE
ONE SCHOOLS I DO HAVE FEDERAL
MONEY AND THAT'S HOW I PAY FOR
MIKE. BUT THAT'S YOU KNOW NOT
EVERY SCHOOL PRIORITIZES THAT
SO I'M NOT GETTING ANY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING I'M SEEN MY
SITE FUNDS IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT BUT IT DOES
TAKE A LOT IT TAKES A LOT OF.
PERFECT DEVELOPMENT ON PRACTICE.
DEVELOP TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT
KIDS KNOWING ASKING US FOR
QUESTIONS WHAT DO WHAT DO THEY
NEED TO LEARN. YOU KNOW HOW WE
GOING TO MEASURE WHAT WE DO
WHEN THEY'VE ALREADY LOOK AT
WHAT WE DO WHEN THEY HAPPENED
TO WE AND OUR TEACHER. NEED TO
A QUICK. GIVE THEM AT SENATE
BILL'S CASH. MAKE BEST
INSTRUCTIONAL THE- BUT IF DON'T
HAVE THE KIND AND PEDAGOGICAL
KNOWLEDGE. TYPICAL TO MAKE
THOSE TO. AND THEY TEND TO-
DEFAULT TO WHAT EVER CURRICULUM
THEY MIGHT HALF AND TRUST THAT
MORE THAN TRUST THEIR ART OF
TEACHING. AND THEIR AND THEIR
EXPERTISE AS A TEACHER. THAT'S
WHY I WANT TO HAVE EVERYONE OF
OUR TEACHERS BE MATHEMATICS AND
LITERACY EXPERTS. YOU KNOW THE
INTERESTING THING WHEN WE
DECIDED THAT- EVERYONE WAS
GOING TO DO TAKE ALGEBRA IN SAN
DIEGO UNIFIED WHEN I WAS ON THE
SCHOOL BOARD- I HAD PARENTS.
UPSET CALLING ME. BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T WANT THE KIDS TO TAKE
ALGEBRA. AND THEY ALWAYS SAY.
ME YOU KNOW I MEAN I WAS NEVER
GOOD AT MATH I MEAN YOU KNOW.
AND I WOULD ALWAYS ASSN THE
CRITICAL QUESTION DO YOU THINK
IT. IS A TWO. AT SALEM. NOT AS
A WITH THE DON'T. KIDS THAT.
BECAUSE MOST. TO DON'T WELL IN
MATH KIDS. DO WELL IN MATH
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALREADY. THIS
THAT IF THEY DO GIVE US OR DO
YOU. OKAY BECAUSE THEY DID GET.
IT WELL. SO WE DO THINK. MATH
COMES. SO I. BE THAT SOME
PEOPLE DO SOME PEOPLE DON'T
THAT'S THEIR ADDED. SOMETHING
THINK DIDN'T GET THE MATH. YEAH
I GOT THERE IS NO MATTER. I
THINK DOCTOR WHATEVER'S ON TO
GO OVER YOUR STE IN SAM. SO I'M-
YEAH FIND A STORIES AND THE
COME DOWN WILL LOVE TO HAVE A
WE DO ROW WITH TEACHER AND
OTHERS TO ALL THE SO. RIGHT
FROM WITH THAT MR MCCARTY. HAD
A- DATA I'M GONNA TURN THIS
OVER YOU MAY WEBER I'VE GOT A
WALKING THROUGH FOR FIVE. YEAH
THESE ARE JUST OVERALL. THE IN
ANY OF YOU COULD. THANK IN A-
THE START TEST IT WAS. IT WAS.
PHASED OUT INTO THE- TWO TWENTY
THIRTEEN CORRECT. YEAH AND- ONE
ONE OF THE INTENTS WAS TO. WAS
TO HAVE A- GREATER VIEW OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER OF THE STUDENTS
AND NOT HAVE YOU TEACHING TO
THE TEST SO. DO YOU AS A BODY
THINK THAT. YOU KNOW FIVE TEN
YEARS LATER THAT WE PUT YOU
THAT GOAL. THE SHORT ANSWER NO
HOWEVER I DON'T THINK YOU CAN
ACHIEVE THAT GOAL IN FIVE TO
SEVEN YEARS I THINK SEVEN TO
TEN YEARS IT LEADS TO THE
DESTRUCTION OF OUR SIZE IS THE
TIME IT TAKES FOR ANY OF THESE-
MASSIVE CHANGES LIKE SWITCHING
OVER TO COMMON CORE LIKE
SWITCHING OVER THE ASPECT
MATTERS. AND AS A BELIEVE IT
MCCARTY OF DRESSES. MISS
WEBBER'S POINT WHICH IS THE
REASON THOSE OTHER SCHOOLS ARE
DOING SO WELL IS THOSE TEACHERS
HAVE BODY INTO THOSE PROGRAMS
FOR STUDENTS WHO SHOULD BE
FAILING THOSE PROGRAMS. WITH CS
TEASER THE START TEST WE BOUGHT
IT IS BECAUSE WE KNEW IT WAS
AFFECTING OUR API WHICH WAS
SOMEHOW GOING TO GET A SEAT
THAT BY PRINCIPLE WE KNEW WHAT
THE CALIFORNIA. LEADS THE EXAM
THE KIDS HAVE TO PASS SO THEY
DON'T GRADUATE SO THAT SENSE
OF. URGENCY CREATED A BY IN
THAT THE ASPECT DOES NOT YET
HAVE WITH. AND SO. IT TAKES.
LONGER YOU MIGHT WANTED TO BUT
I THINK MORE DEVELOPMENT AND OR
RESOURCES MORE TRAINING. THAT'S
THE KEY TO GET TEACHER BY AND
WITHOUT TEACHER BY IN. I THINK
IT HAPPENED. THEIR COSTS IN OUR
OFF IS UNDER AS WE ARE IN. THE
NEW SANCTIONS OUT THE PROGRAM
TO IMPROVEMENT- UNDER NO CHILD
LEFT BY YOU THEY'LL SEE A SIZE
IS LAUNCHING THIS YEAR AND SO
IF YOU'RE A SCHOOL THAT SCHOOL
TO READ AND ALL OF THE DOW
SPORTING CATERS BUT ONE COLORS
NOT READ YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
SIZE THE YOUNGER WITH THE NEW
PROGRAM APPROVED STATUS. SO
THEN WHY ASK TO DO AS A SCHOOL
TO YOUR SINGLE PURPOSE UNITS
SHE MET AND THEN THE DAILY ACE
TO RIDE INTO THEIR ALL CRAP
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO EXPLICITLY
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET OUT
AND GET THE RIGHT OFFICE WE
DON'T WANT STUDENTS DOT BURNING.
DEALS YOU'RE GONNA GET THIS
CREEP BACK OKAY WILL WHAT SORT.
YOU CAN. THE TO. AND START
TEACHING TO THE TEST SO YOU CAN
MAKE THE ARGUMENT. BECAUSE THE
TEST HAS BEEN VALIDATED. THAT
IT'S AS RELIABLE AS THE S. A.
T. TO PROTECT- FRESHMAN LEVEL
PERFORMANCE AT THE UNIVERSITY
FOR UNIVERSITY COLLEGE LEVEL.
BUT WE ARE KIND OF CREEPING
BACK NOW BECAUSE NOW I HAVE ONE
THAT- CONTINUATION SCHOOL. A
70% FREE REDUCED LUNCH 70% ON
THE HEALTHY KIDS SURVEY.
REGULAR SUBSTANCE ABUSE USERS-
THIRTY THIRTY PERCENT-
SPECIALLY POPULATION. AND NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
DO WE BOOST YOU KNOW ASPECTS.
RIGHT AND SO THAT. GOING ON
WITH. INSTEAD WE JUST WANT TO
THE RANGE BE COMMITTED TO THEM.
I AM SO. THE VALUE THE TEACHERS
INCOME INTO THE EDGE COUPLE FOR
CONTINUATION SCHOOL. BUT IN
ORDER TO GET OUT OF. THE
SANCTIONS IF YOU WILL YOU'VE
GOT TO DO BETTER ON THE
ASSESSMENTS. SO THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT OF PRESSURE US TO GO
BACK TO TEACHING TOWARDS THE
TEST. NOW AGAIN. THE TEST HAS
BEEN VALIDATED SO NOT IN THE-
IT'S NOT A BAD GUY SO I SAID MY
FACT. IT'S NOT A BAD GOAL TO
ASPIRE TO. I WE WOULD BE REMISS
IF WE DIDN'T THINK WE WERE
STEPPING INTO THAT. INTO THAT
ROUND SO THE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOP THIS I WASN'T AS OUR
TICKET THE FIRST TIME. BORDERS
ARE TRYING TO SAY. WE WOULD.
MUCH LIKE WHAT'S HAPPENING
DOWN. IN SAN DIEGO WE WANT TO
FOCUS ON THE HOW. HOW DO WE GET
STUDENTS OVER THE BAR. NONE HOW
DO WE- I. UNDERSTAND THE TEST
QUESTIONS SO WE CAN MAKE. YOU
KNOW. WE'RE JUST WE'RE WE'RE
FOCUSING ON HOW DO YOU ASKED
THE QUESTION VERSES THE
LEARNING. THEIR WE LOST OUR WAY
A LITTLE BIT OF FOR JUST TRYING
TO GAME THE TEST. THAT MAKES
SENSE. WANT TO THANK YOU- I'VE
BEEN TOLD. BY THE CHAIR OKAY.
WELL LET MORE. WHEN THEY WANT
TO DO PUBLIC COMMENT OKAY OKAY
THIS IS THE- THAT. BIT OF A
DIFFERENT TOPIC AND I WAS
HOPING- MISTER O'DONNELL IS
HERE BUT- STAFF CAN REFER THIS
ISSUE TEN THIS IS ABOUT. THE
TESTING INDUSTRY. AS FAR AS
ASSESSMENT. FOR COLLEGE AGE. SO
WITH THAT TO. I WOULD NOT. DATE
ON THE- ACT SAT. AND ALLOW YEAR
SOME. AND MISTER DON AUTHORED A
BILL WHICH I SUPPORTED WHICH
SAYS THAT. YOU KNOW NO LOOK AT
THIS THING AS- AND AS WELL
THERE'S A HUGE INDUSTRY.
CERTAIN PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO PAY
A TON OF MONEY AND ON. AND A
BETTER CHANCE OF COLLEGE THEN
LIFE AND OTHER START ALWAYS GET
STICKERS NOT PLACES HAVING
SOME. ACT IN A CLASSROOM TACIT.
ENTRY FRANKLY THE UC BORDER
READ ME GET RID OF THE WHOLE
THING IN THE FIRST PLACE WAS I
THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
VIOLATING AS WELL BUT MY
QUESTION TO YOU ALL IS THAT. IN
SOME OF THAT STUFF THAT I'VE
READ. THERE'S A POTENTIAL THAT
THIS TASK COULD BE AT COLLEGE
YOU READY ASSESSMENT FOR.
ELEVENTH GRADE AND SO FORTH SO
IS THAT A REALISTIC PERSPECTIVE%
THIS POTENTIALLY- IT BE
UTILIZED IN IN IN COLLEGE.
APPLICATIONS AND ANALYSIS AND
FOCUSED ON EVERY STUDENT HAVE
THIS AND THERE WAS AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO GET. FOR TEST
FOR US BACK BUT EVERY STUDENT
HAS IT. YOU KNOW YOU KNOW THIS
YOU'RE NEVER UNIVERSALLY.
AVAILABLE NO I MEAN. I DO AND
IF I CAN. SPEAK TO THE WAYS. AS
A TEACHER AND INDIVIDUAL WITH
MY EXPERIENCE. IT KIND OF IS
ALREADY LEADING THAT WAY
BECAUSE THE OLD EAP QUESTIONS
THAT CAL STATE HAD EMBEDDED IN
THE PREVIOUS TEST TO DETERMINE
COLLEGE READINESS. ARE THERE
NOW IN THE US BACK AND COULD BE
DONE FOR THE SAME REASON. BUT
AGAIN MY PERSONAL LOGICAL BRAIN
SAYS WHAT ELEVENTH GRADERS
READY FOR COLLEGE AND WHY ARE
YOU BOTHERING WITH THEM. THE
OTHER HALF THAT THAT I WEAR
SAYS THAT MAKES THE S. BACK
VALUABLE IN A- IN A IN A- IN A
WAY THAT COULD BEING MEAN MORE
THAN IT SHOULD AND SO I'LL JUST
ECHO WHAT CHRIS SAID EARLIER
ABOUT BECAUSE OF THE STATE.
RIGHT YES. FOUR ONE COHORT IN
ONE WINDOW FOR AN ENTIRE SCHOOL
YEAH. SAID THAT THE ONE COSTS
ABOUT ALL THAT'S- GIG SSNS CAN
BE USED COLLEGE INTEREST
ASSISTANCE CAN BE USED FOR DAY
KEEPING THAT'S IF YOU LOOK AT
SOME OF THE RESEARCH THE DONE
AROUND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM THEY HAVE MOVED TOWARDS
THE TEACHERS GRADE IN A COLLEGE
PREPARATORY ELECTIVE IN ENGLISH
ABOUT AS BEING THE BEST
PREDICTOR FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SUCCESS. SO HISTORICALLY WHEN
YOU'RE USING SOME OF THE SENATE
AS FAST AS A GATEKEEPER
MECHANISM FOR- INTERESTING TO
CREDIT BEARING UNIVERSITY
COURSES- YOU WHAT YOU'LL SEE
HISTORICALLY IS SINCE POVERTY
AND UNDER REPRESENTS ARE GOING
TO REPRESENT A GROUPS ARE MORE
LIKELY TO BE TO DO THE
REMEDIATION OF THE ASSESSMENT
COMMITTEE WOULD SAY WELL NO
WE'RE JUST TELLING YOU THAT'S
WHAT THE RESULTS SAY BUT THEN.
THERE ARE HABITS OF MINE- WORK
ETHIC AND OTHER FACTORS THEY'RE
GOING TO PLAY DID HAVE SHOWN
THAT THOSE STUDENTS WHO
PERFORMED WELL GETTING A HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN I GO HAVE GONE ON
TO THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
THERE ANY GAZING IS AND YOU CAN
TALK ABOUT THE STATE IT'S-
PUBLIC NOTICE TO. WHAT AND ARE.
EIGHT THE SHORT. OF MANY CAR
TUNES WAY INTO NON. GRAD
BEARING FOR. SPECIFIC MEANINGS
LANGUAGE ARTS. AND IS NO LONGER
THE CASE AND THE STUDENTS ARE
PASSING THE COLLEGE COURSES SO.
I I'M I'M NOT STE. AS LONG AS
THERE IS A ASSESSMENT THAT'S
REQUIRED. IT PROBABLY DOES MAKE
SENSE TO ALIGN THE S. BACK. TO
SEE IF YOU IN UC SYSTEM SINCE
IT'S OUR SYSTEM. BUT WE ALSO
JUST NEED YOU KNOW LOW
CAUTIONARY TALE. IF IT'S USED
AS A GATE. TO PREVENT UNDER
REPRESENTED GROUPS ARE A R. L.
CFF ONTO THE COULD ACCOUNT
STUDENTS. FROM ACCESSING HIGHER
ED- THAT WOULD BE AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE THAT I WOULD NOT
LIKE TO SEE COME TO FRUITION.
AND I THINK IN NO WAY. IS THE
ASPECT READY TO BE A COLLEGE
ENTRANCE TESTS. GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES WE'VE HEARD TODAY.
WE HAVE TO MASTER THE K. TWELVE
SYSTEM BEFORE WE MOVE BEYOND
THAT FOR SURE. SO I GET HIGH
SOME SALES JUST DO THIS NOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE TO IT
EXACTLY THEN THAT. WOULD ARE.
ANY OTHER MEMBERS WHO TO SPEAK.
SEE OTHER COMMENTS BUT I
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC MAY COME
TO THE MICROPHONE. I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY STANDING UP. THIS IS
THE FIRST NOBODY COMING UP TO
COMMENT WHILE- SO WITH THAT-%
ANY CLOSING COMMENTS FROM ANY
AND ANY OF THE- ANY OF THE
PRESENTERS HERE TODAY ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS. A SINGLE FOR
THE CLOSING COMMENTS- WILL
CONSIDER THIS MEETING ADJOURNED
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY THANK YOU
FOR YOUR INFORMATION AND LET'S
WORK TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE WE
HAVE A QUALITY ASSESSMENT
SYSTEM FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED.